[Music]
wonderful I have encouragement you have
Courage I have courage we have
you have courage they have courage
[Music]
we can give you a small one then
entrance
a giant round of applause to receive our
first speaker Miguel Ángel
How are you
how are we
how about my mother a little noise eh
host, half the people are missing
Yesterday there were more people and people have
said I'm tired
Well
today I am delighted to be here
today and that's why we're going to start with this
not make a little noise who
get to know javascript to see a little bit of
noise Ay Ay Ay Ay Ay that is heard very
good huh Very good Now what do you still do
more noise who suffers javascript
who suffers how you will suffer
javascript with cool stuff like
This Every day is a new adventure one
it doesn't know anymore when you compare values
references boolean sums you get
super fun stuff how are you going to
suffer you suffer a lot or what Let's see what
say yes or no you suffer
[ __ ] the mother of something else Well then
we all agree In fact many
thanks for coming to this talk
thanks for coming to Victor and see you
next year bye
No man no that there are still buff 45
minutes of talk No man The case is
that when you search in Google if you already
writing is dead you find yourself like
a million and a half results, that is, it is
brutal eh people give him for dead already
and then you go to YouTube and it's even worse
you find these things that Mira says
javascript is not the future of
web development is dead javascript
I don't know if you ask that it's fine
Is that on YouTube you can find
anything later we will see it in
some slides I have to confess one
thing that I suffer is true but also
I love it
you love it too nothing is worth
ok ok the sufferers love it a little
masochists we are here that is fine A
everyone likes what they like, eh me
I'm not going to judge anyone but why should I
love it and why I think you love it
first because it has a curve of
learning hears very good no al
principle well do anything
I can also dangerous because you can
also do anything but
you can use both in
for a lot of stories and the best
everything is that it is the motor that moves
internet the web and the web are all
sites. So that's the best thing about it.
javascript But besides that though the
people say he's dead it turns out
since 2015 we have had more than 50
new features So that for something
[ __ ] imagine the dead
having kids or something like that would be a bit
weird so i'd say it's dead
it's quite alive huh at least it moves
So you don't know me, I'm Miguel Ángel
Durán I have a YouTube channel where I do
lots of content creation
about javascript no video talks about
that he is dead, far from it, nor do I
voodoo to resuscitate him and I also do
many programming streams in
direct on Twitch and today of what you
I want to talk about the javascript of the
future so that we can see that even though
He is dead. It seems to be because he has something
of the future and we are going to talk about how
evolves javas to the Pokémon And it is that a
very interesting thing about javascript Y
This is something that very few people know.
how language evolves and how
javascript evolves javascript has
a major challenge that does not have any
programming language and I don't know if
Have you ever thought about everything
those people who mess with javascript
that he hates it and it is the fact that always
it has to be backwards compatible not with a
or two apps not with millions and
millions of web pages out there
outside. So when it evolves, it doesn't
can tear all the pages that already
there's Internet
and above all it has to evolve with
a sense to just avoid doing
things like this
shame and everything says I don't want to go out
Well, something like this, eh, and it doesn't have a pineapple or
Imagine if it had pineapples or
would be milk and it's hard really a
programming language that within
It's as old as Java, it supports so much.
websites and such always challenge compatible and
also prevent this from happening before in
2015 we had Microsoft which was a
little in this way ok it was Microsoft
Damn what's wrong, it's the same, this is it
programmed with javascript
well, the video can't be seen but it came out
Microsoft there firing shots to see if it
gives the Play no good Microsoft in your
moment when I give it to him he stepped on his own
here here yes I see it over there I don't
I see well Microsoft came out and copied the
javascript code introduced a lot
of bugs and things like that before 2015 or
it was the old East but luckily
one thing we've had with the passing
of time is that the evolution of Emma
Script as it has been improving no and every
year well we have had like a
specification we could follow this
It has been thanks to tc 39 which is a group
of highly qualified and expert people
in fact I have a video to
see if you see a photo is these people from
hereok
What many people don't know is that the
t-79 is made up of people from
different browsers the people of safar
and Chrome and all this and it's totally
open you can go to you can see the
repository and there you can see all the
proposals that we are going to see today and you can
see also each and every one of the
steps so they pass to proposal and
you don't know this anyway but you can go
you and you to github and propose
how javascript has to evolve
anyone can do a pull
request and in phase zero he leaves his idea
obviously the zero phase only the
beginning of a great journey then
We have phase 1 that will go to
proposal we would have phase 2 which would be
a draft and finally we would have a
candidate which normally already means
that is going to reach the browser now that
if you don't die before because we have had
a lot of fixtures in javascript no
is that he dies already, I want to say that
the proposal dies because many
proposals that have reached phase 2
even phase three and they have never arrived
like the decorators and things like that but
imagine something like that with 79 or 79
They are like these people, not and it takes you.
It is the new fixture that we have made
using enjoy it and this happens
continuously. Although we don't
let's know for a fact let's check it out
look a little into the future let's go
forward before continuing I have done
an association of anonymous programmers
of javascript is totally free by
If you want to sign up, it's totally or
you don't have to do anything just count
your experience of what it feels like to
use a programming language
he's dead apparently it's a lie This
It is for you to vote each one of the ones that
let's see today ok you can enter and
participate participate man who is
fun to see if you liked them
new javascript tokens and all this
if the QR code does not work you can
enter to
midu.link/js ok Yes you have it there
Still people. Well, we'll put it later.
again let's start with cloning
objects and arreis this gives for sack or not
a little not a little let's see I'll tell you
a little so that we are in context
the arreis in the objects are
references this means that you have
a King you try to laugh assign it to
another variable And this does not make you one
copy ok this is like the first of
javascript but it is one of the things that
Even with more years than you have, it gives
little problems no and what you have is yes
you to this copy that you are supposed to have
done because you change an element
it turns out that yes the copy has this
change but so does the king
original surprise and this then then
anyone the rule now anything else
we have with this is that when we do
this assignment to another variable if
you compare it gives you true it tells you yes yes this
object is the same and here people meet
think that Ah is that it is the same object
because it has the same values ​​and it doesn't
which is the same object because they have the
same reference the same pointer or
memory and of course this Well even more
complicated because when you compare a
network that actually has the same
values ​​and you have a network with some
values ​​are the same emojis and in another
that has the same emoji you compare it
this is a lie ok then
when we learn javascript like that
nothing happens after everything goes away
So you can do to fix this
create shallow copies we can
do with the slice that returns a new
king with the express
in this case but with the But these are
shallow copies as beware
also with this because if they are
superficial means that they only reach
Miguel What does it mean that if we have a
King and inside it has another King Well, nothing
when we try to do the same ok
I'm going to use spread which makes a copy
superficial but when you try to change
of this copy a nested element of the
network within the network it turns out that also
they are mutating it and also the copy and the
original are modified then of course
My God Enough already well yes I should
to have died apparently
a lot of people laugh like yes yes hopefully
well we had arrangements we don't have this
hack that one feels like a hacker doing
these things of making the copy with the
Jason strangefy and the Jason pass But
this has more bugs than a pond
because it has enough little problems and
done you say you shouldn't wander because
then what happens to you happens to you that's good
Who has not seen this error
Who has seen this fatal tape error
Hill of line 1 and you
looking for line one if it should be the
beginning and that is because he has not been able
correctly walk the Jason when doing
a copy at the end stroll in what
do you have how you can fix it
you can make a handle worth by hand by
what Because we are very smart very smart
I no longer make copies and you do this and
what's up with this? Well then
copy is not exact because there are types of
data that is not copying well
we can do with dependencies ok
well do you care about dependency and mother
mine, this works for the future
well it's not bad because how can we
see then you Here you can have an object
nested with rice with whatever you say
I want to clone this and you then
you put to do what you want him to
original has not touched it But all
these solutions have problems
some a bit hacking other well for
think mistakes others make copies
incomplete and others you have to
download a bookstore a library
which makes you add javascript but not
don't worry come come I will teach
clone objects in javascript to inside
come on
the topic
a new function has appeared
called structure which is very interesting
because what it does precisely
native is to clone objects and arrays of
deep way and does it very fast and
supporting a lot of data types
like for example here as the example
typical we had of a reality
we call the structure we tell it Mira
you have to clone this king and now yes
we can modify all the elements
that we want where we want and how
we want everything to work
perfectly we are not going to have any
problem and the original will stay
perfect very good Now of course
we don't normally have this anymore people
it's like now But what is this this what
can i use only in chrome version
280 and when the full moon has risen for
the window and such Well, not the
The reality is that if you see me on the channel
you have 88% support this
functionality what it means is that in
almost all browsers already have
support you can use it today
very bad if you have to endure
for example Safari on iOS which is the
new Internet Explorer and loves to give
the note as you can see there the only one that
The poor man is in red, well then
you can use a good polyfil This is
structure 38 people I see you
love it very well You can still vote it goes
to be for all the talk Look 40 there in
real time is that with javascript you can
doing these things is even amazing
Look very good, very good, eh, it's going up, it's going up
going up Very well, I'm going to say one
thing What I have just told you is not
javascript
this has not decided since 39 and this
It is a very typical confusion that many
times it happens with javascript and it is that
mix what is javascript with the web
Api for example the ts39 javascript the
language specification what it does
the Arrow functions would be the promises
in the web ribbon the array methods that
yes it is something of the language but there is
another part that we often use
in javascript that is not javascript in
reality is actually from the web and this
the w3c consortium does it and here
we have fetch we would have the structure
Clone we would have for example do
images that may be Lazy There is a
bunch of apis that we use in our
day by day that in reality that is not in
the javascript specification is
use javascript Because that app and
it is available in javascript but it is not
part of language And this is enough
interesting that many times you do this
distinctions because if you can't
surprise if looking for documentation of
javascript on structure well you will see
that does not exist in reality is something that
they are putting from the web How do you
you have stayed uh you have stayed like
the heart and that here with the Pelillos
the truth is that it is a bit surprising
but things that are javascript
the great improvements that come in the
there are many methods of King true ones
how many how many how many do you know how to see each other
tell you the number out loud
one two
three four
I haven't counted them but there must be
at least 20 to make things easier
they will add a few more worth for
that so man is that they have seen that already
you know they said let's put some
how many but the truth is that it has very
good looking for example we have the array
grouping that is already in phase three That
it means that this same year he will
reach all browsers the array
grooping what it allows you is a
kind of sea But what we have you
Imagine you have a network of numbers and
you can group them depending on the
key that you want for example Here
We are going to group these numbers and we are going to
create an object where group on the key
of Even those that are even and odd those that
they are odd and this as easy as three
lines normally this I have to do
with a review or something a little more
complicated and this would be this object
would be the final result this is going to us
make it much easier to create
objects from a king that if not
we had to make very transformations
strange another little thing that we are going to have
Now they are the copy And it is that as in
javascript Well we love fun
What's up we have array methods that
return a new copy of the network and
there are others who don't Ah because you are who
know by heart Let's see if you remember And
for example, the rivers point is one of
those that mutate the original array and also
we have the sort point the splice and of course
Well, you are doing point map point
short point whatever and you don't know if
is mutated that it has done or if it has
exited in x Mena y in the middle So what
that we have Now it will be new
methods that will always return a
original network so we no longer use
the purl stitches that are going to mutate to
original and here you would have the rivers
that will do the reverse of the network but
always returning a copy Same
for the short we will also have the
sun also the wift would be to change
when you are changing a position
from a network element directly
with the point with you would say in the position
1 Give me the two but Give me back a copy
new and we had the same with the two
splice but one of the best things that
has javascripts without any
doubt is that it is multi-paradigm And this is not
It means that you can do what you
I feel like it Well it does mean that
it may be that you feel like it, you can
liar very brown I mean yes What is that but
what it means is that actually
So you have functional programming
prototype oriented programming you have
a lot of types of programming that
you can follow paradigms and one of them
functional programming and one of the
more interesting chips to come
very soon it is the issue of payping and the
payping is not that Mario can be
put through the pipe that also if not
It is a functional programming technique.
where you get the output by passing it
the input to a function this function its
output passes it to a next
function and the output of this function to the
next we are not doing a how
a pipe where we are passing the
information in javascript to do it
we would have to do something like this we would have
function 3 that has to wrap the
function execution of function 1 and
of the input but of course it is a bit strange and
besides that it is backwards it is very
hard to understand in javascript For
Let's see a more real example would be like this
imagine we have a text string
we have two functions one to change
the entire text string to lowercase and
after the blank spaces
convert to a hyphen This is to be able to
create slacks that are the urls that
we believe that they are readable by the
browser, then we would do it like this No
we would have the
we would do it like this Another thing You could
to do is one I don't like this at all
hack not to use reviews to create
a Pipe function And then reuse it
and such good luckily this is over
because we already have phase 2 The pipeline
operator a new operator that will
get to javascript to be dead no
it's not bad huh it puts it up to new
operators I don't know for that one is alive
don't do something do something no Pablo Well in
In this case, look at the syntax
Although you see it that way because they are with
ligatures is actually a bar
vertical and the greater than and what
you're saying super readably is
the title pass it to the Tower Case and the
tolower Case what is returned you pass it on
al adds this on a single line as well
we can write it like this
we could write in each of the
lines and this in functional programming
it will make it stay much more
readably other examples because How do you
I would now do this filter because you can see that
It's a little hard to understand why
you have two functions that are out there
in the middle in the future How can we do
with the operator we will do it like this with the
project will be much easier first
I do the callback and then I deny this and
then filter
There are plenty of examples like this
also that it looks super good and that if it
you see in javascript you start to cry in
a corner
but the best of all and what if there is
something that today I want you to go out there
out and I be the first old lady
That you see, excuse me, ma'am, but you know
He has found out that there will be new types
primitives in javascript
and the lady of course yes I still have my doubt
incredible
looks like my grandson
he is a very good boy no but seriously yes
There's something that
It's amazing it's one of the new things
which will get to javascript which will
change completely no longer as
we work how we learn it
performance of our code is
spectacular today we have as
primitive types strings
and single and the primitive types so that
let's understand perfectly and say
which is the purest way to have a
value in javascript and therefore are
immutable you cannot mutate a string
of text or a number, that is, the two, you don't
you can mutate say no you behave
like a three you can't they are immutable
but of course in javascript a problem
history that we have had as we have
seen are the objects because the objects
are mutable and therefore here we
happens that if we have two objects that
have the same values ​​and
we compare it tells us that it is false and we already
I've seen the face before and look what it's like
dark I have seen the face of when
We have seen the previous example and
same happens with the arreis and this about
everything when we learn javascript we
it costs a lot but this is going to change
because the records and the
tuples which are two new types
primitives that come to bring
immutability to a species Structure
of data such as objects and arreis
Let's see an example for example of
for example of for example of example
of the record
look here we have two records where
Clearly they both have the same
values ​​because they have a property a
with the midu value and when comparing it gives us
true notice that the difference is that
we have a pad in front of it
that looks like an object and is that the
records what comes to replace are the
objects but with immutability the same
we are going to have with the pairs like the
Build like a king and we're gonna
be able to compare by value
but best of all is that
we have deep equality imagine that
we have a Good object a record with a
lots of properties and inside another
record and another record and another record Well
if we create two records with the same
structure the same values ​​and the
we compare we are going to have to we are going to
give true this is not possible today
or do we have to use dependencies of
third that unfortunately has a cost
in very large execution either of the
library load that first but
then also doing this evaluation is
very expensive and this Now would
fully native javascript
having deep equality changes many
game rules in javascript imagine
that in a few years instead of
learn objects and arrests when
we learn javascript we teach it with
situplas record and we explain it is not that
you can compare them there is no
problem or it will go up facilitated the
learning and life what do you think yes or no
Yes of course except the detail the lawyer
of the object that is
No my representative believes that the
mutability is best
be quiet well this is what
we are going to have just with the records
and the pairs obviously there are some
things to keep in mind because
this seems this seems illegal but no
mind that illegal let's go ahead
but you have to have a few things
take into account the first obviously
only works with primitive types this
means that in the records within
you cannot suddenly put an object
that is, you have to always use type
primitive all we have seen
records not here in this case you see
we are using a record within
a record to continue to maintain the
immutability here in this example as
we create a chile and so-if object
we try to use an object or a King
within a record a duo we will
having a type error will tell us Hey
is that this object you can not put
inside a tuple and gives you a type
error because they are not compatible Then
second it is super important that they are
immutable obviously to get
these that cannot be mutated and if not
can mutate means this type is
syntax is not correct if you try
worth all the people that is a record
I try to change the point name You will see
that will give you an error but this is
Great because we're just
getting In addition to being
immutable, we already had to worry about
it is not that it can be mutated somewhere
It's not that he's going to kill you, he's going to give you a
error will not be able to be now obviously
do not worry because we will be able to
modify in a way but it is that for
modify actually we will always
have to create a new record let's
say I want to reuse the record and
change the name This is something similar
to what we already do with objects but
here we are going to be forced, we do not have
the record and to create a new person
with a different name we have to
create a new record From
former
who likes it
It's alright get outta here man this
it's a javascript conference nothing
man indeed there has been a news
quite interesting taxi was going to be
well actually this is amazing
because yesterday I said let's see what the
people I have not found this video what
It says I don't need to use tabscript anymore
more now i use the new javascript of
Microsoft instead has 40,000
views and 400 grams of some
substance this guy shouldn't
having taken is worth it because it does not have
meaning the headline or the javascript
from Microsoft But what is this
very strange Let's see, it's not like that, okay, not this
I will need to use is that never
plus Microsoft's javascript not what
we are talking about is taiwan
annotations and I will try to explain
very quickly because it is very important
that you understand the issue is that this
new proposal called
sure that the same never comes from what
it's about the guys who
we normally use in what we are going to
be able to use in the syntax of
javascript but they will be ignored from
done if you see this code the smart ones
in the Wasps you will have realized
which is wrong is wrong but this code
it will be correct in javascript let's say that
the annotations are simply
comments that are ignored
javascript ignores them You will be able to
put if you have Hey great because
contact you will be able to do the check and such
The idea is that the javascript syntax
are compatible but it is not checking
in javascript so you see that the
title that we have seen before, well, no
It makes a lot of sense and here you can see no
led x String and then I put a number on it
and then in this function I tell it that
returns a String and it turns out that I am
returning a boolean this would be
correct in javascript with the cues Like this
which basically what it does is ignore
Totally the guys and I'll be you
totally sincere the future that I
I see this more or less is something like that no
this do not tell me no
you're good to see
load good is the internet signal
Well then you look for me I'll show it okay
But hey I'm going to do it like the alt
accessibility voucher goes one person
running and puts a host in the
door that bursts it is worth
That's my opinion. Where is it going?
arrive This is worth more or less
the other day I read a super Greek philosopher
stoic and very interesting that the
past experience if it does not fall into the
oblivion serves as a guide for the future is
a very deep phrase that I
found in a fortune cookie
that I ate it yesterday that I asked for Chinese and I
It seemed super cool this [ __ ] this is
like crazy here in the middle and hey well
it fits well here fits well in the sense
that there are times that maybe
tapas notations not reaching javascript
there are many things that have never come to
javascript and many ideas for example already
there was the idea of ​​trying to carry the type
checking the enums There are a lot of
ideas that have never come javascript
for what I told you at the beginning
but it's always good to try and see
what discussions are generated so much in the
community As the different
browsers so although this doesn't
arrived I would not see it as something negative
because in the end and this is a lesson in
life
You only learn by failing, you don't learn
of successes So if Equally this
in the end it reaches nowhere we will have
learned then we have temporary why
Why work with dates in javascript
Well, it's a
and temporary is a new API that will
allow working with form dates
very simple and it is something that also
It will arrive this year, that is, not
we are looking into the future of not within
80,000 is not that in a few months
You are going to see that you are going to have the
temporary availability in your
browsers and working with dates no longer
You are going to need neither moments that it is
dead that yes that is dead and no
javascript
he's dead but good thing he's not going to
need no dependency anymore
to work with dates So yes
temporary since uploaded
directly
We are going to review your votes to see how
you know ported let's see eye hey very
well in the end you have voted there to the fullest
my mother is the one you liked the most
216 I see that you like it but neither
as well as what you say when your
mother in law says do you like the food
Yes I like your daughter more
but it's reality so I eat
I don't like this stew but it's
well okay but I see that more or less well
Well
I leave you the last announcement since we are
in I am preparing a course for
learn javascript from scratch that will
be totally free for
community I hope and hope that with everything
What have you seen today if you haven't?
learned that already I suppose that yes but that
you want to see that this
dead is very much alive we have left
many things to enjoy and that in
reality
javascript has not been better than in
this moment they have been killing him since
I was born in 1985 and I remember the
doctor who told me when you're older than
you know that javascript will die and I will
I said
I don't even know how to talk
they were already killing him every year
they are killing him I don't know someone
they have to be entering already shoelaces
constantly killing javascript
But he's still alive. So where is this?
we are enjoying this conference today
with stickers of so much talent that is
fill the room is just the demonstration of
that you have a lot of javascript left that
enjoy So let's keep enjoying
javascript Thank you very much
stronger stronger stronger
Hey friend tell me how you felt in the
conference in the conference yes good
it looked like my communion
because sometimes the photographer was there
super delighted or with the love of
amazing people i love you so much
thank you very much thank you
Yes indeed that's what we gave ourselves
count yesterday that is the amount of affection
and we were going to ask you exactly that
How did you feel with that affection that was given to you?
was delivering and if there is
chances of coming back here
there are chances
for a while in chile yes 8 years ago i was
in Chile a month a month no it's not
enough to say that live
a time I enjoyed the full
of the
earthquake I never remember the
flea is the traveler
And what did you eat in a boat with a boat bone?
with a bone, please, a bone, a
bone
eh sounds very bad I guess
if someone can get him a boat
with a friend bone and took a picture of him
Not perfect Hey tomorrow Maybe
it is wonderful
I seem to like it more than one
complete but
a comment
able to travel from there completely
in the other side
of all the people
that's not at all thank you very much
organization
totally that they opened the
conference the second day a pleasure
thank you very much everyone thank you
we leave with everything we leave very
excited with a lot of energy and
felt the energy
you deserved it because you compared the
level
not yesterday how did you get from
postconference
no well no But we ended here we were
after another activity I mean but
super good I had a good time and no And of
he's not really that tired
I arrived yesterday
tired and just to see a drama
doramas from here if they are in fashion Okay
Who has seen dramas and Who has seen
dramas
there is a drama called proposal
work I think you have seen
well, it lasts like 12 or 24 chapters, I don't
I agree well but I saw it super fast
and not the doramas They really are very agreeable
fashion and good the only platform in
where I see them as well as calmly in
Netflix what a coincidence you mention
Netflix
[Music]
productivity team
hard work in productivity for
borders So pretty cool did
a chat on the Remix a while ago
so from ahead on
the stage is yours
Netflix
[Music]
louder please
that
show the heat of chile
Well I think it directs me to change this
because
I scream a lot
they told us we had it
Felipe your microphone of the one like this
I need everyone's support on this as well
don't leave me really bad now
suddenly a single view and a single
view
[Music]
beautiful beautiful beautiful
what a fun time to spend
Hey no the first block was brutal
all along we said we had to
make a small introductory announcement
and I left the PC
but of course this ad has to be
completely spontaneous
but you have to move the screen because
it's extended no problem no
problem do not be nervous with the
technology
as it would be noticed that you do not work
in technology
what is sister yesterday now
Not yet not yet not yet what
easy this what it is to ask and how
come on
[laughs]
they finished in the sprint
no no no
Look, I'm going to do it like this because I don't
Let me see the part where I have to do
the presentation
what technical problems we already wanted
we do the same ads these
announcement we usually make it to
start but we didn't want to do it at
start for we didn't want to start like
fast together with me to not
beat it in the morning but
inject them with energy in the sense of
it was early yesterday was a day
tiring today there were people here at
seven thirty in the morning then
you had to inject that kind of
energy Yes stop moving the screen
the first thing we want to do is
thank you for coming by
to be again on this second day of
conference because we know that it is fed up
paste that is fed up that is enough
tiring and that in general Good yesterday
a certain heat today was very early
I mean we had to be like this
What the hell, the first thing is a round of applause for
you please please many
thank you
after the thanks we have to
recall at this point the
thanks to the sponsors totally
to the sponsors who have been doing
gifts to the sponsors who are
giving away those cold mangos and
of strawberries
maybe you tried it better but
ours were from here they got
cool yeah i got it back there with god
no but really
I'm not going to tell you why they
disappeared even my charger
no no because we are all
scrambled but there are so many cables
really thank you all
our bronze sponsors
williams
check list
pretty
and laboratory Yes that I can ask you for a
applause for them please
and also and also for our husband
we also want to ask you for a round of applause
for our sponsors elastic claudinary
Google that they really have passed that
they are wonderful yesterday yesterday someone
won one
like a backpack full of things
yes but like that but literally had an at
inside
socks and yesterday I was in socks
of Google
they stay so they know but
full thanks to our sponsor
goal and obviously to our platinum husband
walmart a round of applause
because we owe them reminders
reminders please are very
important
code of conduct yes we will again
remember why maybe people who yesterday
they did not come and appeared only today
Because they said nothing I want to see that friend
So we prefer to leave the
reminder the code of conduct is
super simple
the after half or after a
event
person did No that doesn't have to be
you the first person who has us
to help continue and strive this
type of behavior are you second
person the people who have these little things
and third point that is not negotiable with
all the love I have for you and the
I thank you for having
come is a code is super simple this
we're not getting dragonic on this
that is short so that they have it clear
and they can scan it if they want a
problem
after that
the same information Valle males of
milk ladies left down underground
any problems let us know ways of
escape this from here the ones that are here
without food in the theater and neither
drinks please, that's what I imagine
who remember this from yesterday Yes I believe
Yeah
thanks now
yesterday we discussed it we have two contests
how are we going to give away at the end
of this conference two little things we are going to
make a little drink on instagram That's the
instagram account
the best group photo we have some
discount codes that you gave us
then maybe we will photograph it
choose and we will give you a code
discount here for each person
of this group photo are little dollars for
be able to buy in the store
that and the second contest we have in
Twitter
the most active tweeter yes
punto cl Twitter put play fed up
the prize is great
and within the theme of the contests there are
something that we want to show you we are going to
share because we didn't really have
thought of giving something based on the best
moment captured but we find
this on Instagram and for real This one is
it was the best captured moment
a little that right after this
talk then to the person who recorded
this video i think we have we have
If you raise your hand, say yes, my account
instagram because
[Music]
the best moment
I think the best part of this video
It was the cry of Felipe
[Music]
Something happened at that moment I really
I want to ask that the person who is the
owner of this instagram account
can come
a round of applause while walking this part no
is ready so
How cool because as an account of
Instagram Anyone could raise the
hand we would have known yes
make itclear
that's what we want to do
delivery of a small booklet here at
center please because if you don't they're going to
say that from the photo true
And above all
we almost got shut down for breaking that
smile
pretty pretty everyone
Thank you very much thank you Master and
with what was like the prize
We already set them free so that no no no
no You have the other the other part of
Instagram because there are already many people
participating and there are many group photos
that have been uploaded
Show only some there are people who have already
thrown away as well as certain little things in
instagram is not that these people
have priority over the rest
when we choose it, no, but there are some
photos that were taken here I think it was a
cluster
[Music]
internet good the case what's up
He told us that he liked it a lot
but that with that we close the first
block we leave them free we return in 20
Ah, they are already telling us why we have
to remember something come the
If I'm not mistaken, the orchards go to
eleven o'clock in the morning there are still quotas
available to register there
there is the workshop that is from claudinary
that moved from yesterday to today yeah so
if you are looking for the point
they will be able to see that there are quotas
available for those today we have
a mail
the important point is that the garden
[Music]
that if they can if they want to attend the
Wonderful workshop, it really is a
crack that invitation delivered look for
the quota register and enter at what time
what time
Thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
I've come
today
How was the break How was the
break Yes already good perfect good good
good
in fact now we come just to
continue with this block which is
much longer we have a circulation
double double double and let's go
start with a national product, well
seems true because
like the saying if it's Chilean or good
yes we are going to start with national product
and well we are going to share a little bit of
information about him he is lord of
Walmart
[Music]
well accompanied by
I like it I like it I like it
that and since he was little he has been passionate about
informatics told us when he had
11 years old he made his first development
I'm making servers for games
very curious
I hope it is
and from there we work on many areas of the
software development
yes our first chilean speaker
flying directly from the States
United we receive With a loud applause
Gonzalo Fernandez
come on crack
[Music]
the first time i was in this place
because my mother brought me to see the man
What gives you to see the butterflies was a
one of the first works that was done in
Chile with so much technology all the
digital stage everything was projected and
well the years go by here i am that was
a sample of the latest technologies
that they had will be that today the story will
repeat
Thank you very much my name is Gonzalo
Fernández and today I am going to
talk about empowering
javascript a case applied to the
education
OK then
although this talk is sold as a
talk later
I come to talk to you about a lot of theory
computer science sorry
but they are going to like it let's talk
then about a preamble regarding
How did we get to this situation where
I had to use let's talk about
how are the programming tasks in
introductory courses from there we go
analyze what we can say about how
complex is a programming task
followed by a developed framework
for this same and from then on some
conclusions with interesting data
regard
so this is me
I love how presented above
everything that is computing and see how
you can do different things with all
the tools it gives us
one of the sectors in which this
I liked the teaching a lot
amazing things we can do
with programming with systems with
everything we have today
to teach to make a better
partnership to deliver better
tools to all people
there is a lot that can be done in that
sense and much of my career I have
dedicated to investigating what can be done
about it today I find myself
working as a developer at Walmart
I was in the United States for a program
what are you doing monthly to send
monthly developers to know
technologies from there and coming to
bring them to Chile there is much to respect
to many things that I take and that I go
seeing how they can be integrated into
this of the teaching of which I am going
speaking As well as I participate in
what are the oscilabs workshops, no
I know if anyone has heard them but they are
some introductory workshops to
programming for young people from seventh
fourth half are completely free
and they are developed online
from basic where you learn
block programming with scratch
logical thought from there follow
intermediate with c++ and finished
advanced with competitive programming already
the most advanced that we can explain
in this area too
we already have more than three thousand
students who have been through this
we have had 87 tutors who have
supported throughout this journey already
There are students who have participated in
international competitions of
programming that these have come out
workshops and have classified and well the
Today it's been four years and this
2023 will be the fifth year of oscillating
This ad space is for you
invite your friends and children
etc. participate are all
welcome I also participate as
sorry
programming coordinator assistant
Federico Technical University
Santamaría This has been a team of
helper over the years
I wanted to acknowledge everything
the support they give me who else
All this closeness that I've had
how programming is taught has taught me
led to go see what we're going to take
in today's talk but before
we need a little intro on
at least in the holy university
Maria or the programming course
divided as follows There is a
little previous work where the
students are learning the concepts
from there it continues with a first session
in the week where the teacher solves
doubts, it goes to a session two where the
teacher develops exercises in a way
supervised with the students and from there
in more this is continued with an assistant
does not perform the class of the teacher
They make a student who has already passed the bouquet
Every week you see a concept
other than either sequential programs
cycles conditions etc. and each
week is accompanied by a task that
should develop in their homes without
embargo
programming tasks are not something
as simple as something that is going to
deliver only one note then to whom
more we can see one of the
examples that we have up there is the
mascot of the programming course
called kiwi and these are a tool
that serves various purposes
throughout the educational process
student In fact they are So the
homework is a very important part
important part of the teaching process
learning This is something we can go
seeing in different investigations with
pretty strong claims but
they really give value of what the
homework are throughout instruction AND
is that well the tasks are taken care of
measure student learning
throughout the course, that is, we are
teaching them well the students are
acquiring the contents
It serves to encourage a task well
made makes a student who does not
had in the programming memory the
time to see on your computer that the
result I was looking for
excited, likes it and starts working
Facing what could be a future
yours in this world there is more allows the
student apply everything he has seen
in classes, stop seeing the teacher
writing code on a whiteboard or
his computer and he starts typing and
gives him face-to-face feedback What are the
mistakes that can be made What are
things you can improve etc.
however
tasks must meet some
requirements, ideally it should be a
real problem that is
many times we can solve tasks in
the things that have to be done
absolutely impossible to happen
and therefore the student is a
little confused and what is it for
this really has to be
interesting
I know that those who have had tasks of
programming has happened to them that they don't know
have to calculate their dividends or
something zero that interests you that
active has to try to be something
nice interesting for them and they have
to have a level of difficulty
right and this is where
we are going to concentrate
yes ok
tasks are not always perfect
homework very poorly done or a very poor homework
complicated is generating disinterest in the
student ie
it begins to demotivate with what would be
learning computers is no longer interested
participating in this generates frustration already
all this begins no I'm not done
for computing I am not made for
engineering etc.
start cheating if possible if
is that the homework was
asking for the codes and
when reviewing it as homework
it's so badly made we don't even know
What things can we talk about and what
feedback will give the student is
but there is very good research that
talk about how students feel
when developing a task and it is
that this diagram, although it is somewhat
complex part of the idea that the
student begins to develop
task is encountering difficulties
and depending on how the task is and
how he is facing the course
can deal with them can progress
in his task he can get frustrated and stop
you can feel bad about it
learn can hand it over or just
can desert all that is that at
end of the day the big affirmation of everything
this is that the tasks should be of
quality and this is where my work
thesis comes into play and it is that how
we can measure how complex a
task What tools do we have or what
exists
does or
one minute
I need you to upload the images
sorry
OK
I had taken my cell phone so I
I will bring the internet 50 years ago
Mauricet published a book called
elements of software Science in this
book he wanted to raise the software the
code done as a science as well
in physics we can
determine by basic formulas
aspects about the bodies to say know to
the speed that something moves
position in which it will be in a
given time he wanted to determine things
about the software using also
formulas determined by him
this book that he published speaks a lot
about how we can estimate
things about the software only
viewing code
he defined different metrics is the
vocabulary of a code that is
basically how many operators and
unique operands has this is its
how long is it how many uses do these have
operators still operating has already
volume that is based on the size of the
implementation effort time etc.
of all these metrics we are going to
concentrate on one that is the effort
How do they think one could determine
how much would it cost to make a code you guys
they are facing a code of some
implementation of some algorithm and
they mean ok my students
they should develop this they will be able to do it
not an exact same code but
could you make a code that does
Exactly the same
here is something very interesting that he said
he if we
we abstract a little from what is the
programming to which we are
accustomed if we forget the
classes we forget about inheritance
contractual underlying polymorphism
etcetera all those basic things the
last I made it up
we can say that programming is merely
or good Any program will be able
be seen as a set of operators and
a set of operands in this code
for example we have that the operator
comparison the modulo operator
etc. and the operands would be the
numbers we are using the variables
and everything these operators need
to perform your operation
This is the minimum level at which
we can see any code and it is that
the same today the syntax of the
languages ​​is much is very different in
compared to how it was 50 years ago
when you did your job still with
a little imagination can be of
agree with me that this is the minimum
form in which we can see Any
code done now well what good is it to us
this
Let's think how we could make a
algorithm that is capable of generating
any program any code yes
we know what base any program
is a set of operators AND operands
then the correct choice of each
one of those operators and each of
those operands will generate a
code here for example is an algorithm
that as long as we're not done
our code we are going to ask
our brain to perform a task
cognitive search for what is the operator
what I need and make me program it or
well look up what is the operand that
I need to pass an operator so that
do your job
This algorithm would allow us
develop any given code and go
very hand in hand with what our mind
It has to be funny here is that
we have in our brain
all the things we need to use
when it comes to programming I don't know a God
effects for react operator module
etc. We also have our
operands, that is, we see a
code and we do for this code has
numbers has some variables has
some texts etc. those are his
operands Then if we
we would like to estimate how difficult it is
make that code what is the process
mental that today behind developing it
We can go imagining the two things that
we have in our brain to say
operators and operands to see how many
Sometimes we call the functions of
our previous algorithm
as a code is longer
we need to call these more times
functions and we need to give it more load
to our brain in the same way if
we want to pass this a code
when our brain finds
the things we need that there they go
marked tells us that we hurt and
so we are programming this is a job
as a team now well as any search
you don't always find what you need
at the beginning and that is something that happens to
our brain we can see
as if we need we are doing a
code We need to know what the
variable that we have to place now
our brain starts to think it's worth
see what operands we have there is a five
it works for me there is no full it works for me there is no
a bar finds it works for me yes perfect
They hug each other and everything Good teamwork
and asks you to write it then all this
mental process made by our brain
to determine what to put code of
what is the use of knowing this
hamster used relied on all this
beginning to start defining various
operations several numbers and several
calculations that we are not going to enter into
detail and determined numerically
how many how many cognitive processes
How many calculations How many searches
make our brain
develop a given code and
interesting about this is that now
we can measure based on a
code how much does he have to think
student to solve it further if
We know numerically that
a code requires about twenty thousand
mental operations twenty thousand processes
cognitive and that the human being can
carry out eighteen of these processes per
second Then the estimated time that
someone would take time to make a code
is the number of processes it does
split 18 the guy is amazing and this
it was 50 years ago
with these metrics we can go
calculating things from the Software and go
estimating beforehand as if you were
a science of physics and say where it goes
to be such a thing or to be predicting things
however
all this that is here is just theory
So how could we
implement for our teachers
we have you who developed your
metrics 50 years ago then we have a
teacher who is writing an assignment
for your students and then you should
solve it to have the Guideline we trust
when all the teachers do that
there in more once you have your code
Solving the task this Guideline He
should pass it through the metrics
hamster And then realize that
is about to shoot his
students if it is going to be very
complicated if it is going to be very easy
etc. from then on he can take or
not the decision to do homework anymore
easy
so to achieve this for
facilitate the teacher this work my
thesis work is a framework called
It doesn't really mean anything but it sounds
excellent
well I won't be much but this is the
final tool has several sections
but since I have eight years of engineering
I learned that I can then divide them into
this first on the left there is a
part a task editor where the
teacher can write your homework this
idea is that the teacher can have a
simple tool to start
writing in many universities happens
who is the teacher who does the homework
latex the teacher who makes her fat
teacher writing it on the notepad and
it becomes quite a mess when it comes to
start doing more standard tasks
so with this they can already
write well in
other languages ​​more in case you want it
learn teachers
and to the right
that is not very noticeable but there is a
analysis of the code that solves the
task the input that is above the
teacher should write What is the
solution of your task in country in this
case in python because the whole course of
programming the in python and you will be
the cycle metrics will appear
say how difficult your homework is
depending on how many processes
cognitive the effort for this task
for example the solution required
90,381
cognitive searches to be able
be solved and had a complexity
cyclomatic of Fourteen that those who have
gone the walmart orchards should know
upside down what does that mean
Now here are some suggestions.
the teacher compares this effort
of this task with what was the effort
of last semester's homework and if the
teacher went very well to fly
suggests that I make it a bit easier if
the teacher did a very simple task
it is suggested that you make it a little more
difficult that last one does not usually come out But
there has to be the suggestion And for
last there is a configuration part
where the teacher can see
historical metrics regarding how
been the work of the tasks that are
making comparison to solutions
of the students, although they are
metrics on one side of what the
teacher develops there are also
average metrics of what all
students deliver here is an example
for the files task this graph
It goes by semester and the green line is the
of the professors Daniel Suárez that of
the students
what interesting for example that
we can see here is that the complexity
cyclomatic of the first semester
teachers had made a solution that
was much more difficult or complex than the
solution that had occurred to the
students But the following semester
wrote a task in which the
teachers' solution was much more
easy than the solution made by the
students from here we can go
removing several interesting things to follow
watching as the teachers
improve or worsen the writing of their
tasks over time and how
students are affected by it
Here it goes, you can graph all of them
Halset metrics among others to
to see how this is changing in the
time now well Beyond all this
investigation
there are two problems with the implementation
of this framework one is that it is very
hard it was a university once
that the student is entitled to leave and not
come back to hear from her stay a
system that nobody is supporting
well it was him it's always difficult
maintain a system without support but in
college is harder because
no one takes care of the servers this
they can fall and they don't get up
systems etc. can happen many
things therefore had to be found
a way to distribute this framework
in the simplest way possible and hopefully
on some public platform where
Let's trust that no one has to be
doing nothing about it and the other great
problem is that to everyone's surprise
the library that computes these metrics
in python is written in python
So like I did like all this
system is cheated Script to be able
distribute it easily as a simple
band The Static What we started to
to do was see what he could do roe
sow to help us And it is that it is a
technology that really came to save
this thesis of this poor aspirant to
engineering because it allows us
execute a series of instructions
binary
any type of system in this case
browsers have implemented the
app of and therefore allow us
run whatever code is done
with his thirst for instructions
means all this in more words
Let's imagine that I have a
program in c++ I have this code I do it
I compile and the gsc compiler or else gems
is going to give us a binary This
binary is an executable if i drag
this binary to my browser will not
being able to run it turns out that Chrome doesn't
runs ago more more was a surprise
complicated when I saw it but
if instead of compiling this code in c++
with most gems we use a compiler
pass it to a web assembly binary
So
the browser if I'm going to run it
and that's where this starts to come back
so interesting. Because I can't just
do it with eyebrows more i can do it with
python with golan with any language
which is not javascript and use it with
javascript or the plugin that is
here is incredible and it is that
There is, for example, that it is the lichess that it is
this page to play Chess online and
the game engine is basically a Port
of a game analysis engine
chess called
on the web this and other types of things
more incredible you can see them in
In my case, what you need to do was
run python in javascript then
we have our code in python we have
C payton What is the python interpreter
since python is not a programming language
programming that we have to compile
we have a question mark and we have
than see how to run it in the browser
What's missing here That was what I needed
to be able to continue my memory and it is that
seeing and seeing it turns out that a person
beautiful developed that is a port of c
pythonsembley now we have Payo Drive
have
a way to run python in
our browsers and therefore
we have a very simple way to be able
run the theory we need here
we can see that we carry what is
the library that allows us to execute
python code about
we can just send our
console the result of executing the
following code in python that would be
Show the version of the module with
I am
we jumped all the barriers that prevented
see this topic on metrics without
embargo
the library we need is called
multimetric which Calculates metrics of
cyclomatic complexity among others
comes natively in
but These guys are so amazing that
developed
micropit What is a micromanager
python packages developed for
to be able to install libraries on the web
So now if I needed this
version of multimetric simply
I tell piote to load micropit and
with micro pip ask him to install the
library that I need This is what
same as doing pip install and the name
from some bookstore to work in
python but now we are doing it in
the browser is something amazing and there is
someone else
I what I needed for my bookstore
for my framework that is what is in
the final code is load
plus micro charge to be able to install the
library and running the installation
as if it were a native installation of
python is loading in my browser
And then I can work with it
metrics calculator i needed
for tasks thanks to this is
then it is possible for the teacher to write
the solution of its the Pattern in the input
that we had seen before and
running this code in python which is
the one that delivers the metrics with several
rides in between
we can have all metrics AND
then we can determine how
complex is the task that the teacher
just developed
from then on here you can scan the
alpha 0.001 of the framework if that
someone wants to try it This is not so
I know that it is very badly done and there is
things to improve but in case someone
wants to see and already done this some
conclusions about this work
note that with roe semry as we are
loading several libraries the fact that
run this code even though it is not
complicated because you just have to
loading it from the page is a banner
quite large and this measure that they go
going bookstores can be more complex or
slower on the other hand
there are various metrics on how
teachers have been changing since the
conditionals task where the
students always did homework very
complicated compared to resolution of
teachers to the task of cycles
where finally the students could
approach the solution of the
teachers this has been improving a lot
in programming Y as you go
having more data we can see
how this framework has impacted
impacted the development of tasks
and well people said this before
end five years ago after the
publication of the book it was determined that
metrics had none
application neither in engineering nor in
nature but I can't read so
that never stopped me
thank you
with more force
wonderful Hey to you we don't have to
explain to you what is true is not
outside
Hey national product
how much motivation
in United States
[Music]
of your time that you have traveled first
that nothing Avenida give a talk
talk was very very entertaining and that
so we want to give it huh
In fact there is a point
you leave on monday there are more options
go ahead see you half
That's why I ask you, can it be something clear?
whatever and they'll see we had it
with all the people is open is the
forced point to say yes public
and eventually we will bother you for
something but that Exactly Please many
thank you a big round of applause and thank you very much
before leaving we have some
reminders one there is a jacket
Lost jean outside so yeah
someone got lost is in
accreditation
but if they want it they can come to it
look here or maybe I can leave it there
in Olympus with the kids true
I'm going to say yes, yes, look, he's gone
raising your hand that but we
they ask us what a problem
that with the lost things and another
reminder the workshops continue to
Half past two is coming if I don't
mistaken
with the tic guys and then
Julián, it's like four thirty
so check that you can still
enroll so they can so we
we are now that we were behind
we were talking with Julián who
is looking at the orchard
entertaining that Hey but incredible about
that is, one when he listens like I'm going to
schedule in
she
was not was brigid was was was
astatic aquatic
Well now we have to move
and we move from language we return the
English Yes so let's start with a
Interesting topic but before doing
the intro to our speaker I have one for you
risk question
the party
having so much I thought that this
we talked behind
with much sincerity we were behind
talking And Felipe asked me Hey
what is your favorite robot right by the
topic and I just like that out of nowhere I tell him the
route
he was laughing like five minutes
[Music]
So we want to ask everyone for a
big hug for our next
speaker for colin
and it is a general hardware kit
I really like the topic of Hardware So
that
[Music]
a
it is not when in general we do not see
playing with robots is sitting at the
in front of a computer elbowing or
they lost the forests trekking in
general true
[Music]
Thank you very much
One
digital maker
[Music]
Jolin
of physical
[Applause]
[Music]
Rumba Rumba Rumba
we want to ask you now
Yes, they can give you a big round of applause
how nice when troubles happen
I think I'm going to have to change
favorite bot
very good
How was the talk?
They found
good
[Music]
we are working with microcontrollers
Hey, I have you for before we continue
with the with the conference
but I know that I know that you are a
cultured man quite cultured of course
Excuse the things that really
matter of course therefore My
question is the following what is your
favorite anime
[Music]
I would say evangelion but they are going to say Ah yes
typical but i love it
its endless and metal but brotherhood
or the prize now
[Music]
now last because I grabbed it I'm in
a pinch more or less
already my recommendation
it's like the beginning
with all that we were saying
about the anime Mexico included we have
a surprise Yes that from our
precisely
infinite memes knowledge of memes and
more importantly also of Java and of
technology. So imagine all that
mixed in second person and we have
our next
in web Technology and Google Maps
platforms faithful believer of the mdd Meme
Drive
taco lover but wait for that
I should say I guess that's
with they are not car blocks but
We have to ask if you know that Taco
is also like Yes because when one
ask someone outside that one
call so much elsewhere
We can already say that we do love them
tacos
Now with that same strength and much
plus a round of applause for Joel Gomez
[Music]
I have to do some exercises
Well
let's start with this so that
soon we will go to lunch because
we are surely hungry
[Music]
to improve maintainability and
performance
First of all this talk is dedicated to
mydog
left us last year but
you still there friend
then thank you very much
I introduce myself I have already been introduced here
but
that is Joel Humberto Gómez paredes I am
Gemini because well I do that's why I am
good side bad side win the bad side
of Then there is no roll
This is pokemon master
and there are my data if you want
contact me is like it takes a while but
I answer Okay now little one
disclaim what I say and my
Opinions do not represent anyone.
toast that something happens
I have a question do you want babies
since I answer if I want ok ok I'll go
to ask again they want memes
exactly how i had to answer
Ok let's talk about architecture
Okay I'm going to speak a little slow to
give a chance to the people who are
translating
basically architecture is a jutsu
What do we do to define what it is like?
software is structured and how
the parts interact with each other more or
Less it's like that horse, dog, I don't
I agree how it went but
and fulfill its purpose which is
pass me the butter or in the case of
Internet Explorer was Download Chrome
relax
Ok I'm going to move little by little
because there may be a lot of new people
There may be people who are not so
new and may people there are people who
Well, literally the code they do
it already turned into oil then
let's go back to basics
this is web architecture
ready
is we had these interesting things
like Ah the internet we have a server
we have a client we request things
Dark sun I remember that even before
we used something called maybe the
new do not know ftp
[Music]
you took your files, you uploaded them and everything
It was magical until this became massive and
well eventually we had to improve
the architecture but in essence it continues
working the same the truth is that it continues
being the web based on html with
resources like
really not much has changed was added
what they are probably laughing at
I hope they are not and if it is not like
OK
Well we had this customer base and
Okay server now that's the way it is
the architecture in which we communicate
what we need okay
then came this part of
architecture in applications normally
what we had was something called
multipage application
in the past those who visited blogs and
that kind of thing what was done is
literally every page when
we need a page was delivered to us
Now if the same html and when
you wanted to do an action, you loaded the
same html but the
parameters by the url yes friends it was a
Wild world so
too wild before bitcoin
so
then they said hey well
I'm always loading the same
resources again and again we did not have
such advanced caching mechanisms
and an idea arose not for good or for
bad that is Okay I'm going to take
a chorus if they do p double a again
this would be like the equivalent of Axel
which is all the things i need
load in my app should be there
and I'm just going to load the page
per page at first we did
bad for regularly almost always happens
not that way
and we loaded everything at once
they said Hey how about we load it up
dynamic way Ah what a good idea
treasury to that man
if someone is not taking notes it is the
time to do it
But before we get to the part about
patterns we have to understand how
the web works and here they may be given
headache maybe not i hope so
I don't want lawsuits or any kind
this friends is the critique of the render
Who has heard of critique render
raise your hand
Okay this is going to be harder than it
I believed
well the web as I told you is based
in html css and javascript there is nothing more than
take the egg out of the equation
then normally htm the web is html
driven because html is the core of the
apps because you can't load
he is going to write directly but
makes the requests is html So
when we make a request
we get an html we start building
the dom and we get those resources
resources usually have a
hierarchy and can also be
blocking or non-blocking and if
want to know more about this can you
contact later to explain
how is the wave because the time is
limited then and we don't want
no one there is a talk after this and
no one wanted them to be merciless with Osma for
you say no you won't leave me don't stop me
eat
So we built the gift that I think
everyone knows him but also
constructs an object called
model and then we have the resources of
javascript javascript resources
are usually low priority but
they are blockers why because they
can affect the tree that is built
of the Don and therefore the browser tries to
if there is one of these resources do not draw
nothing. That's why before people
old ways took the Script and Lo
put it down before it
will invite the
they keep doing it's like friends
you have to update then
now why should i know this before
knowing patterns is basically
because it's like making reality without knowing
Yes do a Led without a repeat a
condition more than once use php or
spot
if they saw how I made it in the form of
reggaeton and that
No but this is the real reason
I mean, I know that people love what they do and
that we love the web and we love
make software but in the end
performance and maintainability as it is
money is like your your application is
very fast like this but I spend a lot anchored
It's like it's not in the end It's all money
as Mr. Krabs
Now I have a question and I want you to
that they answer me they want to continue with the
demo want to continue directly with the
demo or want to see theory then
I'm going to ask the three and shout Okay
One Two Three
the demo is gone you got rid of me
so
let's see renderings
generation that this I tell you is something that
It was already there but it is gaining strength again
time It's like football alive in the form of
records
we have in beer rendering because
you say hey what taxi we rendered in the
server Hey we already did it Yes but
now it's different
he has a new hat
we have the rendering we have the
increase in generation status and the
progress and this part of Architect that
It is like I am going to mention some that
have been launched not basically with the
beer party
but like everything it depends on the type of
solution that you try to do the
rendering is like Oh, I don't have seo
I say Well, if your application does not need
seo probably
be a better option the detail is like
how fast do you want the
user interact with your application
when you have the serverside part is
as you render you have a skeleton
already pre-drawn and you do the part of
thetation but the part that is
complicated in quotes is that you have
to pay a server that does that
So for example in terms of
setting up a website is much easier
do the rendering part because
it's literally you take your files what
you put in an ftp that is no longer used and that
is deployed then there are many options
how to render how to deliver
the applications and none is better than
other some are more suitable for
example This build is quite useful
when you have many things that don't
change. But the detail is that when you
website is very big
you are going to take a long time in the vile for another
side if you do the incremental generation
is that it will continue generating according to
it is being requested that for this As of
that Ah It is ideal but you are adding
some latency to users when
be generating it by not having it generated
So you have to consider what is
What is ideal for us?
So for example of beer
rendering is very interesting but for
example we have this part in
we have certain metrics. The point is that
the content Food Paint if it is not right
optimized or in the sense that you are
you are not delivering the minimum necessary
It may be counterproductive why
Why will it take longer to render?
because it will take longer to get one
answer that if you simply sent
things
and the render option is like Ok
this is simpler But the detail is
that until it reaches the customer If you have
a very poor connection is going to take
more I tell you it is a matter of putting everything
in its right dimensions
and for example comes this part of Ok I
I have six rendering I can render
all this will not be a problem
but normally what we choose is
progressivity that is like good
you have to have your components you are not going
to hydrate everything at once but you are going to
moisturizing as you go
needing here you can use certain
types of strategies or certain types of
patterns that I am going to show you and also
you have the Architect part which is the
that he has been taking a lot right now
strength that is
there are things that are going to be static and there are
things that are going to be dynamic Therefore
I have to submit the applications and
control what is rendered how
renders And when it normally renders
what we use are certain patterns of
interaction
but there are more here raise your hand who
you agree with this with this point
the reason for all my problems but
also the solution
we have the dynamic imports that serve
to do this part of speaking which is
OK instead of having everything a good
just separate it into buns
And we have another pattern called
interaction is for example if someone has
loaded youtube widget
you will notice that it is very heavy then
normally what is done is a YouTube
what is that Ok Until the user
interact with it I will load the
true to save me enough
kilobytes in this case is like that
Hey the fake YouTube took me three
kilobytes and when you load for
interact already charges you the 540 of the
widget Then it is as if the less
Now he is going to write executes is much better
indeed a good javascript programmer
the last thing I want to use is javascript
there is a love relationship there
the invisibility amount which is OK when
you have many elements
there are other techniques to load crowd
of elements but usually there
some that are not even visible
in the then
why are you loading this too
includes the part of the images when
you add certain attributes to them which is
so you don't charge unless you are
wearing
split based on paths
which seems like a very popular dance but it is
a way to do optimization Indeed
when they add a package to their
library check Bull phobia check yes
he has three and it's like, go ahead
Give it brother
and it is something that I call I made him driven
web because I am a very lazy person and
in the sense of what I shouldn't do
more steps than are necessary to
develop a task then they have to
pay attention to the law part if
loading load only when you need
In the end, don't load anything that doesn't
use or do what you have to do
Only when necessary
Yes I know
now apart from here new ones have come
opponents that is for example and Astro
that they have a lot is this part of
isolates in architecture that they are going to see
things that
other things are going to change but not so much and
other things you say you know what
I'm just going to load the javascript
when they need to do something not in this
case are their products different but
the approach of trying to use less
javascript of the necessary is like that
It is something in common they are very interesting
I recommend it
and then we come to the good part
as I was distributing software yesterday there was a
quite interesting talk
one where they spoke in federation mode I
I'm going to talk to you right now about
basically the microphone. It's more of a
part of how is the organization of your
product you cannot implement
microphones from the beginning repeat
with me you can not implement
microflones from the beginning repeat it
please it's true eh they can't
increase microflons from the
beginning thank you
the part of mute federation is little
complicated basically you what you have
It is applications where you can expose
components and applications where you can
consume components an application
it can be both So if here if there is
as Cross dependency of an application
can depend on another and vice versa
time then
this is quite interesting because you
It allows
reuse dependencies which is one of
the problems you have when you
does in microflones which is like
I guarantee that I am not carrying two or
three times no even though he tells me
you are charging more than once
and there is a part that is even that who
is that you have heard of Edge
computer
raise your hand please
that there are several This So basically
it's like we have a serverlest in
where are the edenes and he takes care
Like it's the closest to the
possible user and then we can do
interesting things with for example the
translations or run some things
what or do for example this part of
clutch that what it does is replace
certain object within a response
And finally there is the part
ecmascript modules using for example
things like sky pack which is a cdn
smart and using only javascript No
need
the dependencies and just me
I import a module using
yes i know then
how long
I have how much time I have left with the
fingers for
fa ya okay It's cool Good okay This one goes
to be the most complicated Hello World ever
universe
says it That's right we all start with
Angel
I hope it does show up on the screen okay
here we just have a
this is an app makes true
should run
Ah well, you already saw the result
So no problem Ok here it is
All I'm going to do is discount it in
line because i can't code live
because I'm running out of time
I just tell him that he has to load
something that is in a place literally
this Hello World has five servers
running to be able to function
everything can be quite complicated
if you put your mind to it, it's like a pizza
familiar that can be personal
Don't clap I haven't done anything
OK
Here what I'm going to do is simply
I am going to copy this why because
I say the time I appreciate
So I'm going here and I'm just going to
remove these
I'm going to paste it here ok
i will save
I'm going to give ya in starprood hoping that
demo gods be on my side
Ah yes yes ok there should be something
different now okay here it says hello
I told them it's a Hello world
overrated
sobertecsia there is no deceit now where
is this
it's in this folder that says hello
literally this is a web component
look here are my servers
this is a good make up
I literally define a component here
which is called wyonola simply has
this template and already the interesting thing about
this is like what
For example, I can change it here
and the app has no idea what
it is what it is simply there is the
time thanks ok
And don't need nothing but cigars
javascript that is, they never saw a part
who did en bondo the part of the
main app i just told
Hey Google, here is a javascript halogo
I might as well have done it, oh no
I have it that's how this is here sorry
I have this code here that is not visible
which is with little element and uses sdn but
due to network problems it's like not
was going to work so I did the
component literally by hand do not
make friends then Well we already have
Hello now let's go like Let's go
put the greeting of
I'm just going to put this component
here
and
I'm going to copy the amount obviously
now you will ask me this is
application
literally no he doesn't know where that is
component, that is, there is no package that
Be called
simply in the webpack it is here
setting
in the webpack I am saying Ah friend
there will be something called and it is in
localhostres thousand one and there is a Remote
inside and it's like Okay here they are
all the packages you can import if
they want later they look for me and I write to them
how it works is quite interesting
and now i will stop the execution
because then to make the new filter
it works it works cross your fingers this one
and pray what you know
the following is one that is medium
tricked right now you will see why
where is Okay and just for him
last component i will add this
and i will add it here
repeat after me I will never wear this to
unless absolutely necessary
please
This is something called I put it like this
Why not? This is not part of the standard.
of the wrecc is like just like a
proposal So to speak And then and
she has no support and here I tell her
just Hey just Give me what
It is in the port at the local nine thousand
one
OK Let's go Well I have to stop and
restart
because technically i'm not in bed
if they had milk they wouldn't need that
but there it is Okay and I'm going to load
Oh what happened
well nothing I don't know what it means
that, but
here I go here
this is here and he did not replace it with
what Why do I need a Proxy I need
something in milk that does this
Fortunately I have something in it
port ten thousand
if anyone understood Ben's reference
10 is like it's one of mine
let's see what happened
and here what happened is that I have a
little Proxy that was around here or something
maybe not here it is that what he says is you
you will respond to what is in it
port three thousand that is when you
request you go for what I am in the
port three thousand when you find yourself
something that is a
it will make a substitute for what it has
in the source So if I go here in
missource is like what it says here A
where is
Chile and well, nothing more to see if
it's working i'm not kidding you
oh yeah i'm cheating
what happens is that usually
when they have these technologies are very
cache sensitive Why Why not
we should be running most of
once and we should
There it is then above all I hope that
they liked it
to my house
can i ask you again please
applause
[Music]
[laughs]
Hey we wanted to thank you first
because
my mom tells me that not with the media
get nowhere
I don't know where it is I don't know if the truth came
Hey hey your talk is wonderful Ricardo yes
is a question that Felipe asked me in
reality and I love your hat and my
question is I want to know what is the
answer But what is your favorite anime
The truth the truth the truth the truth
But the very sincere truth that Truth
what hurts
My favorite anime is Naruto No not because
a matter of how he is the best
studio anime but that is it
is apart
no, that is, it is a study because it is like no
I had many friends and I grew up with Naruto
But which part of normal Naruto the
filler I think Shippuden because it is
when was this when i was
growing up or literally I grew up
with naruto
and the best ending there would have to be
had was to kill a certain, that is
That was the final battle
[Music]
existed is like the Matrix movies
after the first ones as they are they are not
Perfect canon I already loved that one
answer That means that for you
at least what appeared with that
advertisement where Madara appears
eyes and says they are on YouTube was
exciting everything that happened with boruto
That's still perfect. Now give it a round of applause
for Joel a round of applause for
fire him
and I want to pretend that I understood part
from that last section of the conversation
but no I did not get bored in the filling and
there like I didn't end up seeing anything good
or not well well we have our last one
block
and that is our last speaker all the
Reason in block number two we start
of the block opening with products
Chileans and we close the block with
Chilean product we are the best country of
chili brother
So that Hey we are
commenting to the guys behind me
they really like this style of talks
because like they're behind the
curtain
They show you a little how we are going to
talk a lot about technical stuff
general and obvious but suddenly
these things that speak a little about how
we live a process within this
company is usually not discussed
a lot then I like it a lot
[Music]
not totally agree actually
our next speaker here many will
they know he is a crack nowadays he works
in Uber is also very close to the
communities to share knowledge
perform to perform and participate in
they
osman is a developer who enjoys
much continuous learning from this
always looking for new ways to
improve as a programmer and as a person
Yes look how evolved
Hey, that really likes programming
functional architecture software creation
of very fanatical content and the music I
I remember a livestre where we would go to
get together to talk before and we delay
because I was explaining theory
musical I found it very entertaining
I could never learn it because no no
I have the ear but I found it cool
So that I can ask you because it is from
right here from Santiago, applause
giant please for him please
come on
[Music]
I'm from my screen if you see my screen
like in zoom not like the last one
talks remained have been all
virtual stranger to stand here in front of
a stage to see so many faces and feel
nervous and just commenting before
with Joel during Colin's talk
I hope I said it well that he told me
commented
I want to have her enthusiasm
no and literally then goes out to the
stage and transforms into Chris Rock
in danger and leaves me the bar very high
so good thanks
thank you I hope you are well
the talks have been very funny and
Wow I'm honored to be here
in front of so many although I don't see any
hour
I want to talk to you today about a trip that
the one that many people spent during good
almost eight years in my case it has been five
and how does it have to do with
acquisition of the company in which I
work or the one I went for
Hired who is a cornershop and how did it happen
to be with the Shop Bayer true so
these talks are called with the Chapa
uber a javascript ride does nothing
so pretty in english or nothing more pretty
but
Well, let me introduce myself, I'm Osman, I'm a senior.
software engineer at Uber and I want
emphasize that because I finally know which one it is from
my role we went through a process in which
all of that was pretty hazy like that
that's good, it's more clarified like this
that is appreciated well I am fronten
developer since 2014 I am
autodidact
I think something important
particularly now that there are such
that education I think the industry
it feeds a lot on people who don't go through
traditional education. And I think that's
something very very powerful since the year that is
March 2018 work in cornershop
since February of last year I have been
working at Uber I'm going to explain
how did that happen as they already said I am
functional programming enthusiast
I like the clean code a lot
dream about those things and I'm a runner
amateur and if you follow me on Twitter at
@slab will realize that
probably now 99% of things
I'm talking about is running and the 1%
they are rams against Well no longer btr but they are
things related to javascript me
you can find on my website there
there are all my social networks too
I write from time to time
and well I also have a couple of
items there
and well, what is this talk about?
basically about the challenges that
facing a growing organization
As Felipe said well, it is a
looking back over the past five years
of my career
and what this talk is not about is not a
qualitative comparison between technology
and development practices between two
companies because I think that would be that
can be put in a table basically
and say to cause this that we do this
and i think it wouldn't be so much fun
and so?
now again the opinions expressed
in this presentation are exclusively
mine and do not represent any of the
companies I work for
And if much more preamble let's go
and one of the people I most admire
one of the things I have learned the most in the world
of the Software Industry is hicky
that has absolutely nothing to do
with javascript the creator of a staff
of a character of a language of
named programming
and a person who inspires me a lot
actually because of the way
communicates and by the things it communicates and
he always splits all his talks
making definitions of words already goes
and says Okay I'm going to talk about such a thing and
take that term and put a definition
from Wikipedia and then start to
elaborate on it so I'll take
borrowed a page from his book
talks and I'll start defining something
that the word I wanted to define is
trip but I think again in English
that word Journey has like
connotations like
a little different
to Spanish and also as
much better than a javascript trip
Well here Wikipedia says that I always
I pull the definition from Wikipedia because
it's awesome Wikipedia good at
several there is one with which I'm going to
stay but it catches my attention
the number seven that one like one
herd of giraffe in english is
basically a Journey
good fun but I keep the
number two that is the most like that
This is useful for us and says that
well in a figurative sense it is any
process or progression that resembles or
which is similar to a trip especially
one that involves difficulties and
personal development and I think it could
say that the vast majority of
people who have been
involved in this process
have met many
difficulties and it has also been
generated many development instances
professional and personal in my case has
been like that so I wanted to share that
experience with you
And we have here an illustrious poet and
20th century essayist Ralph Waldo
Emerson who says that life is a journey
it's not destiny so you have to
focus on what one is doing
continuously and not where it goes so much
who is also another poet and essayist of
beginning of the 20th century says that
important is the journey not the destination
and I think we can't anyway
forget where we came from and to
where we go because a lot of what i go
to happen in between depends ultimately
from Origin and Destiny
Now if the origin of the destination comes
it can be the same for everyone everything
happens in between will vary true
So I think that this is basically
as a personal experience rather than
as
use it as a generalization of
everything that is happening
And although destiny is very important
many times like that particularly in
the world as startups and companies
like they want to enter the market and
find a Niche that destiny is good
diffuse, that is, it can be a goal like
survive
or find financing but in
general no no no not very clear what
does it mean that or how to get there true
and when we are advancing
we can take that point of origin and
finally look back on
what has happened during the course of
our journey that is very important
because it's the only way we have
finally learning is like watching the
things we have done well seeing the
things we have done wrong where we can
improve
and what are the consequences of
our actions too then I think
that is something very interesting to work on
in product and I for example not A
difference from a consultant for example
that in product when you commit a
mistake after
for a long time
instead suddenly in this in works
as consultancy is more a bit like
Ok finish a project and go to
next and then you forget and all
that as a technical debt that you could have
generated is forgotten then I think it is
very something that I think everyone
we should do sometime
work on product
Well, as Don Jorge Agustín said
Nicolás Ruiz de Santayana y Borrás according to
an arm or George for friends
who cannot remember their past are
condemned to repeat it and the version as
already from History Channel it's like or from radio
bio-bio is like
those who forget their history are
Condemned to repeat him Well then
we are going to do a little
trip back in time to the year 2018
which was when I entered with him
Well, how was it with 2018, I'm going to
assume that everyone knows the
company But not really because there is
people from outside too
let's give a little context
good with the year 2018 good a service
dispatch of merchandise or grocers
basically it's like a copy of
Instagram but in Latin America
I mean not
sincerely
Instagram very very inspired by
Instagram founded by three entrepreneurs
Chileans well no three Chileans two
Chileans and a Swede who has lived for a long time
time in Chile they had already had some
as successes in the world of
entrepreneurship with things like nibich or
clan discount that eventually after
it was acquired by grupom so there is
people who already deep down know how to drink
something build something and
market it if you can call from
TRUE
or make it successful
at this point with this he is three years old
so a relatively young company
but in terms of technology the same
three years is not enough
at that time we operate in two countries
Chile and Mexico I think here in Chile
We were only in Santiago and in Mexico
from Monterrey and Mexico City
and around as the staff of
plant, that is, without considering all the
choppers
surrounded like ninety people
seven out of ten of those people
three of the
remaining were in Mexico
three out of ten members of the
company, that is, 30% are part of the
engineering team and all that equipment
of engineering is here in Santiago de
Chili
and more or less doing math the
engineering team consists of a
twenty-seven people approximately one
team or be equally big
of those 27 people only three are slow
not only three do
and I am one of them
AND
yes i'm a slow runner too no but
no matter how important it is that I want
do this is like
generate some context of whats
the scale Or which one How many are the
amounts of resources we are
targeting javascript already because
We are going to see that with this it is not a
java company finally
Ok What is the relationship we have with
javascript at the time good Anyone
Have you heard of the term?
innovation budget
yes no I don't see anything good Okay it doesn't matter
I assume so although someone said What
But good innovation budget
what this article basically says
dan maquini is that every company consists
with three innovation tokens when
begin you have three tokens that you
you can spend as you want or three
innovation tokens
and basically what he wants to advocate is
that we have to choose technologies
boring true because they are technologies
what are they going to give us?
certain stability with which
we counted at the beginning in a company
young
now those tokens later can go
growing true
to the extent only to the extent that you
company becomes stable
and mature but in general the trend is
that people tend to overestimate the
amount of tokens you have to spend
then he says Ah no I must have like
I can invest in five new things
and make sure that my business is going to be
a success from a point of view
technological when deep down it is not
So
and what happens is that in corners then
to get javascript is one of those
innovation tokens
I'm talking like the
2018 I mean, not a little earlier maybe
but more than javascript itself is like the
one page app development
that is, without blow said publications that
it's basically what he's like taking
this innovation token and spending it
we are spending on it now
It's basically because with this I see a
python company that is, he uses himself
python extensive
because a language that goes a lot
versatile that serves many things and
also
there's a lot like machinery behind it
that one sees as a client when he makes a
order
and we use Dyango that for people who don't
is familiar from python is like the king of
Ruby
Ok simplifying a bit
which is like the relationship that exist
between this system of volks
we interact as with two types of
customers one They are like the customers who
the people who buy and the other shoppers
that the people who make the purchases and
leads them to customers
100% of the traffic from the choppers is
Mobile or is from a
phone because it would be quite strange
see someone in the supermarket
walking with a laptop true it would be
quite strange so that's why the
traffic from apps
mobile and on the client side
majority buy for their phone the same and
very few buy on the web and in fact
the Split as of iOS and Android between the
check out side as the amount of
check outs that are made in
mostly iOS at that at that
moment very few
on the web
but there is also a part like
support that supports or
support tools for choppers
which are also made on the web but it is
very small and also a lot of
internal tools than in the background
decade here true because we use
we use django as with your system
templates
and when we need a little
interactivity we use
when we need a little more
interactivity, that is, it will have a
prettier graphic or do something
that require more complexity
we use angular
and sometimes both at the same time because
lol you only live once
now understanding that most of
these systems are being built by me
respectable backen friends who don't
they have to know javascript
then it's completely fine
Well what happens here a couple of months
before I joined this
company is not that I got to save
like something happened
who contributed to this as to ya
it was like a little vinified
and it is that this application of customers
you were using the Rest Api or
Well
communication by http
via Jason
Not necessarily network but this apis
Of course they were communicating with a
frontend of a client in angular Yes Y
that like it wasn't climbing very
good development of that application
and at that moment the decision was made
logic And probably and logic that
any company at a time like this
when you see yourself developing a product
that it is already difficult for him to develop
and what is to do a complete rewrite
right wow what a great idea
and what we did was well what
they did because I didn't I didn't I didn't
participated at that time was to emigrate
this app from angular Yes to react
we had already had a bit of
experience particularly with the car
shopping using react So in
the background was like Ok it makes sense to go out
of angular js that at that time already that is
Google had already released Angular 4
it had finally come out as a version
stable of the new angle
But in the end we decided to go with react
and migration, like all migration in the
background no no it didn't happen very well well I mean
it was a bit of a fall and what happened is
that in the end this sensation of
that building that piece was like a
stuff
maybe not so useful I mean not not useful anymore
complex of bone has a complexity
extra that maybe one suddenly doesn't
wants to deal with that complexity and therefore
that this innovation token was used
in
and in summary with this it is not a company
that is, this relationship is not because
javascript be bad
itself but it is because it is not a
company that is not an expert company in
javascript is also not a company to
who likes javascript and already writes in
We see the background as more necessary
now this goes is like good it's not
like we have a lot of options no yes
It's like you go to the browser and it's not
like hey I'm going to use No lie
well that's all i have to say
about that that as context now in what
part of my arc me as a developer
from javascript I find myself when I enter
a connershop was at this time in
the life that I think we all go through and
if they are still not arriving they will arrive in
that we use reviews for everything including
when it's a little unnecessary for
example here I am doing turning
a String using reviews and in the
background one can find you can
do basically anything with
reviews and when he discovers that it's like
Hugo
true a String But hey it was a phase
fortunately it's over
and of course as I told them Solo
we were three people working
exclusively in frontendes two of those
people were on the team
customers here there was an opacity but no
you can tell i was working
in the stores team that in fact the
stores team did not exist good And that
[Music]
one of the challenges probably
we approached at that time was like
scale our amount of trades
that we had in the marketplace because
until then there were only a couple or
there were a couple of supermarkets that
they were reluctant indeed a couple
of pharmacies and bye and all that like
operation of maintaining those catalogs and
that kind of thing passed through our o
either he was in charge of maintaining that
operation and deep down that is a bad
way to scale If we want to scale the
number of stores there are because
that is, they need more people the more
shop more people then what
we built was basically a service
self-service where anyone who
I had any store without
import your size can sell through
from with the Shop
filling out an application and then
basically like good you can operate
and you have an application
administration of your catalog and
availability of your branches and
etcetera etcetera
well all that did not exist
So before all this was pure Campos
you can see landing was fine
nice before there was absolutely nothing
and in fact what I inherited with him
team I was working with was
an app called merchan
Center that was made with this
trifecta of
of the devil
and angular
and the goal was
go replacing all these things to
incorporate react because we were already going
I was kind of determined that it was going to be like
the framework that or the library that
we were going to use for all
developments
And now what are the characteristics
of the code that I receive or that my team
receive first is non-minified code OR
it is there written in the html as is
there is no Babel and what happens is that
are using as Xbox features
2015 which at this time did not have
support in the browser then from
suddenly it happened that a report of
a mistake and it was because of course someone
I was using interpolation with template
with templates And that was like this
I mean, I wasn't sweating
javascript that all browsers of that
time they could understand there was use of
ebal also directly as Take this
wave declares an array Let's see the
evaluation there because I need Data by
example that that that that comes in the in
the Temple of html not that sanitization of
inputs and well we have and angular al
same time as a bit redundant
and what happens is that the backen is a
monolith finally because it is
giant python app
and the merchant Center is inside this
monolith
What are the characteristics of O is
what good things the little monkeys
monoliths have a lot of things
good but one of the bad things is
that any change that we
we want to do for more like
irrelevant that it is for example here
I am changing the rim spokes of a
button from 16 to 12 pixels If I want
roll out that production change got
than deploy the complete monolith with
all the things inside and this
for example Or sometimes literally
there were changes of that style like
fix a margin here and I have to
wait 15 minutes for circums to have
the diplo and why am I displaying everything
he is running all the tests
etc.
well and other things begin to happen
quite interesting we have a
love affair with walmart where is
the people at walmart
[Music]
It's a little flat that buku but I
I know why it is a loving relationship
valued at $225 million
Walmart wants to buy it with the Shop and
we are all very happy because Wow
money as I said everything is money
well at this point the company already eat
which is quite big, that is, and we have
many more people and we divided as in
four true business verticals
store and brand clients
and each of these verticals
worked autonomously although
have in common that they all work
in this django monolith at least in
the backen side
they begin to pass Well more or less
I wanted to explain the organization
engineering team is already close to 80
people
We are already more frontends. In other words, we are already
approximately seven
But what is happening is that the
coffer that is like the organism of anti
monopoly if it can be called a certain
way in mexico
opposes the purchase of Walmart by
connection or with facts by Walmart
to form Walmart Shop or whatever
so the deal is off Walmart says
Well I don't want
but it's all I don't want anything so I know
dissolve the deal and the best way to
mend a broken heart true is Hay
a saying here that is like a nail pulls out
another nail
and Uber decides to buy with the chop and for
one is much more love because there are 400
if so if we can use the
money as a measure to quantify
love that thing you don't really
It is but for the purposes of the talks and the
double love because there are 450 million
dollars, that is, I think that la la does not buy
of wall de conners by walmart like that
inflated the value of Corner also good Y
besides we were also
growing as a company at a very fast pace
accelerated
then the friendship ended with Walmart
now Uber is my best friend
the funny thing is that when this happened
literally a lot of people posted a meme
similar in slack internally and it was like
Oh what a fome not being able to publish it
true I think that now it has happened
enough time to do it
well and that's how we transformed
now
we continue to grow in demand scale
Engineering people already have like
two hundred people all this is like in
a maximum period of two years
Not actually a year and a half because this
It's like the end of 2019
we are more frontends like 20 and the model
organization of the company stops
make sense because the basically by
the needs and scale of the business
The problem is that the engineering area
is exceeded by the amount of
operational load that there is, that is, there are many
operational processes that have to
perform engineers because we don't have
tools for operation people
can do those
those processes and what happens is that that
slows down innovation and development
of product Then there was a moment
like the end of 2019 that felt like everything
that I was like very fome it was like pucha
I'm like keeping code
we're not doing anything like fun
nor new and here is like a change
organizational I hope no one messes around
pull this slack image i pulled it
Well, he's already about two years old
years then it is relevant now but
well at that time it is defined as
make a focus that there will be a
product area to focus on
innovation and will also be central
Ops what is he going to try to do
is to solve this problem
scalability that we have then the
solution is to solve the tasks
operational through software
measure or that was to measure and that
software you have to build it true
we build ourselves no no no no no
we outsource
And that means that the product no longer has
to worry about operations and it is
free to innovate and do things
interesting for end users
because deep down that's what's important
always think about the user is not like
ok let's use
and to achieve that we need much more
people
and some other things happened too or
I don't know if they found out
of the friend that there was covid and what happened
is that the people who were locked up in
your house add to that a service
dispatch of merchandise and what
we get is
and this moment is super sad anyway
because it's like a feeling of memory
an email that he sent or went once and was
speaking one of the founders and tells me
this is very sad because the world
it was destroying everything was very bad
people locked up in their house health
Mental everywhere but it's like
we have like a 400 percent growth
cent in the last I don't know three weeks or
be a question is absurd then
I mean, I don't know, it's like a feeling
bittersweet
and this good as such led us to another
growth spurt process
and many people began to arrive and the
consequence is that there was a time when
in our day to day when it was like now
bastard stop everything you are doing and
We are going to work on projects
performance optimization because
we are being very inefficient in
various parts of how we communicate
with the backen or how we make certain
tasks and the backen also in Yes so
we are going to
fix this because
we have like an expected life that is
here I don't know six weeks If things
continue as such this is going to explode
because it will no longer support the amount
demand
also what happened was that like
we started having these problems
operation many began to arrive
tickets to customer service Then in
One moment we were all customer service
for a day, that is, we went to solve
tickets as customer service because
there was a crowded and gigantic amount
It was an enriching experience and
also how we had to hire
many people
How did we have to hire so many people?
we started doing many interviews
interviews I remember that there was a
period of about two months where
I was doing between two to four
weekly interviews
interviewing people because we needed
hire a lot of people
and suddenly they asked me hey why
they are hiring so many people like that
people do not want to work here and it is
like no seriously like no one leaves
a long time ago but we need a lot
people that's why there are always oppositions
open
well as an anecdote during the
pandemic we break our
commercial relationship this time with Walmart
so we're not your friends anymore
again and an alliance is generated but
basically because Walmart wanted
also prioritize the development of their
own product what is
completely fine
well and you ask me now and the
javascript where a trip was called
true good the answer will surprise you
and that basically nothing happened
no not many things happened
because
no no how do we stick a little to this yes
ain't broke don't fix it and we
until then what we had
developed was like a
way to develop these projects
software that served us
I mean we were doing single
using that is now that it is like
fully verified Back then
it was like Ok let's use
what do we do with these apps
are deployed as a static base on a
baquet of WS aws we have a cdn of y
ready now yes
we have quite an infrastructure
robust when it comes to unfolding
these products but we depend on the
availability of people
infrastructure because they have to
set circumcities for example
have to configure
domains and a lot of things like that
so each team is not yet an owner
completely from start to finish
bring a a product a service what
be
each team maintains its own
applications some teams began to
grow so much that between them they had as
upload teams and wanted to share things
So we found ourselves in this need of
make a private npm registry what
we did was look for a dependency
that there was in epm that was like José a
your own private npm in or registry
npm on amazon on aws we had to change
some things in that code and at the end
we stay with our own
internal record and is in a package to
WS and all the but I want to stay with
this last part that all teams
face similar challenges every
one solves them in his own way because
we work on this like
of this structure in with these threads
vertical and how these threads
verticals don't talk much to each other
and what begins to happen with all this
is that the quality of the code begins to
lower
because a lot of people came very fast
also and we did not have as processes
of architecture also defined
and the answer to that was to create a
architecture team and what it did
this good architecture team had
as two separate responsibilities
the backing as it was still a monolith
what what what the team did
architecture was in the background of the afternoon
mediate the relationships that each had
one of these I was wrong
or no I was not wrong
Ah of course it doesn't matter they had to mediate
the interactions between each
this vertical thing that basically does not
there would be no problems
on the different front because of course
I told them I want to keep that part
that deep down
in the front what happens is that
all teams do things
different So they all have the
same problems and solve it
multiple times then suddenly
Someone came to ask me why I
I became part of this team
architecture today osman how can i do
this internationalization looks at this
app we do so could do it
so then another one from another team arrives
Hey osman how can I do it
internationalization Look Do it like this Hey
osman like And so on then
it was like ok we have to somehow
being able to reuse things and communicate
So what we did was do
bookstore and this is like again
javascript make libraries that solve
common tasks such as internationalization
a design system
centralize configurations through
a template or all the configuration
of authentication those that that that the
frontend applications can talk
with all the environments we have
and that the same as configuration of
continuous integration is in a
template whatever you want afterwards
create a be a new application and
run as a command line
generate a template you already have everything
configured. So all you have
to do is develop the product that
you want to develop
Now the problem with that is that it's not
we have a file there is no chip like
of that layer because we eat from
the architecture team I built
any of those things
we can give all the guidelines
one wants and if you carried in this way
do this this way but if I don't
I can give support
it's very difficult for people to say okay
I'm going to take this and I'm going to
incorporate into my development process
So it's an adoption issue.
where I can't force you to do something
If, furthermore, I do not give you guarantees of
that I will give you support
I also have to convince the rest that
my solution will help them fulfill their
objective and also the idea is to provide is
provide the tools for the
rest can make your job simpler
and no more complex then here we fail
us but someone who does it very
well it's Uber you would have this but in a way
awesome
and a little bit of contextualizing What is
Uber's relationship with javascript
[Music]
This is a snippet from the blog of
Uber engineering an article that
since 2016 and deep down they explain
that
the engine of execution of the trips
originally it was written because the
event and etc.
and in fact it was one of the first two
companies in put don't get in
production that is
they spent their they spent their good
touches of innovation in that no
but hey, finally we reached the year 2022
[Music]
well I have never bought a company
of technology I doubt that here
but I think there are several reasons
Why does a technology company buy
another the first is like taking it out of the
market if it is direct competition
in the second it is because it has a
product that works the third is
because they want the users of said
true product and the fourth is because
you want the people you want the people you
built that for you build it for
you true and I think that here the one that does
makes more sense from my point of view
the last one and what happened is that
we started migrating here I missed one
slide like people walking but give it
we began to migrate in 2000 to
end of 2021 trading people started
I went to work in Uber as already
I commented in February 2022
And what do we find? Well, we
we find all that as a structure
of support that
I was trying to build in with
he with the help of some colleagues and
here i am mentioning some like
technology and things but deep down no
It's like entering talking about them in
direct But all these things are
held within Uber by Uber and you
They provide support that you can
focus only on developing your
product Then the framework As of
fronts
which is like isomorphic for applications
universals is kind of between like
all the ones i've seen between remix next
and
gatsby and fusion is probably that
has less magic but at the same time has
more magic but there is no like thing or
be when you develop in fusion is
how are you making an application
of any react That is, it does not have
no special test that if i
etc.
[Music]
So you can search for it in
Internet
What is the component library?
Uber's design system is also
opens
Now regarding how Logan is not like
who wants to boost the use of their
products as personal opinion but not
it's like good people go
conferences to say how
that is, one as there are two talks in
internet of What is fusion and did it
probably good the maintainer that
work at Uber and explaining in the background
Hey we had this problem and
we solved in this way So if
comes a tool that solves a
Uber's own problem
Youtube is also bringing this thing like
What does it have to do with communication?
services solves it atreyu is a layer
of service communication that is
that that is not public And also all
web services are in mono repo at
a monkey repo that is built with it
there is also a work team
in charge of maintaining all
infrastructure thing that one that
work as a product team
we could say it can solve homework
operational
Ah well Yes I laye So if well
we had arrived in our
this solution that we wanted as
solve this problem as operating
Large as amount of operations as
building software for people
I could use it and solve those tasks
basically, what Uber does is solve
technological challenges infrastructure
through software as they are
these tools that I just gave you
comment and what are Software that you have to
build and that are built within
the same company and probably the same thing happens
same in other large companies So
engineering teams no longer have
to worry about the tools and
are free to solve problems for
end users
finishing up final thoughts
And I remembered this movie click
because there is like something is like a
feeling similar to me that he saw me do
this transition from with the Shop to Uber and
It was that I feel like I lost like years of
my life not in the sense like oh no
Too bad but I saw how the development
from a company from a scale Tan
small to become
engineers that fit all in one
office they saw each other every day to pass
to be good I did not give the final numbers
But the engineering team of having
about 500 600 people
frontend are like 60 something like that
a lot of people then I saw how all that
scale process and
when he got to Uber I think how old
we lacked we lacked to be able
reach the same scale
us and that's like what leaves me a
little bitter but I think it is also a
good experience
know this other reality and well
friends friends thanks for your attention
And that have been all
[Music]
Thank you so much
Hey sorry the Exact
Today we are very grateful for your time
very grateful for your talk about the amount
of knowledge of the good memes of
everything actually
the process of moving on from what comes in
quotes is a startup there literally a
slightly larger conglomerate is
quite noisy
and new ones that enter So it is complex
it's super complex yeah wonderful hey that
So we want to thank you very much
With this very loud spontaneous applause
Hey we have two announcements true super
short to be able to release them first
the lunches are already
Yeah this time it's no joke
and on the other hand the workshops start at
half past two there it is from
document updater
register those who want to participate
at half past two and half past four
Julián Duque is coming that so
we wait back at two thirty
to be able to continue with this
[Music]
[laughs]
[Applause]
[Music]
How was the break now good but
good with encouragement good good good good good
good
that's good up there it seems to me Hey now
I'm up on stage so no one
can you tell me what to do so now
yes i will kill food
but i was waiting for them to let me
when the cat comes out the mice do
party so but no you can't hey
I'm alone on stage because
I will be alone for a little while only
let's make a little panel now
where we are going to invite certain people
which some of you have already
seen on stage others not and others
They have seen them in other events that we have
made now from the same conference
take out my torpedo before buying for
do not condone me because I only only have
a certain limited amount of power
improvisation that the stage is
super neat and clear we are going to invite
these girls and boys to talk a
little now with us
We are going to talk about a topic that I
I find it super cool and that the truth is
I miss a lot and that's precisely why
we invite them to
relations de almost I don't know how I don't know if it
have seen has anyone heard
previously this talk
someone previously heard of
concept of advocate before this
chat yes yes everyone someone here works
from
the bottom is in the bottom Look wonderful
precisely for the same reason
we want to invite these people because
is super popular in other languages
where I mean other languages
but in Spanish
and that is precisely what we want
talk a little about where the
concept what is and the truth as
move sticky style so that will
I want to ask for three big rounds of applause and
I'm going to segment. So the first one is
because I want to ask you for a round of applause
Julian Duke
please
Listen to Julián, you already saw it, you already saw it
Do you know Julián opened the conference for us?
Julián works wonderfully
Adriana where are you Adriana I'll go later
to ask for a round of applause for Adriana
Hey Adriana, I have mentioned him every time
I talk about our sponsors and every time
I'm talking now about Google for example
I say Adriana a sun of person she is
Adriana for you to know Adriana
he was with the boys who went to the altar
what we did in the farm offices and
to the previous event that we did the
conference will most likely be
have run into Adriana or if they went to
try to get socks from google
the tomatoes later
that And last but not least
important I have our third
guest our third guest of
fact will be now in the closing of
the conference with us then
you don't know him officially
they have to give sight outside is very
you may have seen it on the net
So I want to give you a
introduction to Ramon
applause please that
Hey Ramon
he works as
[Music]
Ramon
23 years
more chilean
that of Ramón's accent is precisely
because because he spent a long time in
Chile that. So I'm going to sit at the
side
to sit with you and I want to leave with
a little question
today we should have the conference
whole with this little chair here They are very
rich
because I maybe we have or change the
little chairs that we have behind that
the questions are super simple We
Maybe we have suddenly shared it with
with some guys back here but me
I think maybe they have asked
many times to start with something
simple but
what what does a
anyone this is a super open here
where came to clarify a little thing for
for Felipe The scolding or the Ah is not going to
challenge I already learned how to say
Chilean no lies
normally it is not a Red the deprel is not
the charge the
short for developer relations or
developer relations is like
the term covering a quantity of
professions that one can do or
perform to build relationships with
developers practically between a
company or a product that is for
developers and developers
who use that product, let's say the
position that we or people would have
they could be working inside
an organization known as
angelis or develo or Community manager there
a lot of different roles
that can be said to be covered by
this same
by this same term basically a
duty the operative a person who
works for developer relations se
responsible for making that bridge between this
company or this product or this
technology and
[Music]
the people who are using it
normally or the main category is
companies that have a tool or
a product that its user target
they are developers
apis developer tools cloud platforms
etc. Not necessarily companies that
take care of that but also
have that as your tangential part a
super Enterprise company that sells a
saas product but that offers an IP already
there for other people to build
about your platform. You also need
developer relation I am a person who
be in charge of making that bridge between
both don't even make any sense right
is that Julián said that he was going to do the
controversial and now I am going to do
They do call us I am one
my position is viveloper relations by
short
go out playing
its most complete title nobody is going to me
say and serve
this one yes and adding like a little more
Well, we are like user zero
then we usually have
least some development knowledge and
just to have that conversation
with the engineers who are perhaps more
focused on the code and how
engineers
sometimes we go to the context of the rest
of the world
and then we as the first
technology user because we can
make suggestions of either what it is
most common in the industry in this
moment what people like who have
come to talk to us
Telling what they are doing And also
we can say hey this would be great if
had a tool that was a
Magdalena and since we are engineers we
we put in we do the hacking and we do it
life easier for others
developers. The idea is to make them the
life easier for you only that
we take care that they tell us how
I love that people make my life
easier with pleasure
What I liked about this
conversation so far is that already
Define from scratch how complicated it is and
how blurry is the concept of a
through different companies and
institutes because of course it is completely
different then of course he puts a
a little harder to define but I
i tried it once i can try it
because of course the one from Real a series of
efforts that a company or
Open source project to motivate its
use and
point for me
[laughs]
one dynamic another dynamic
Hey, I love myself very clearly, thanks for
for explaining it to me
I had a second or several
questions but and in that case in what
moment you tell your story
labor is history as a professional
they say that effectively what I want
do how I realize what
I want to do is work in this area of
network in one of all these edges that
implies we can start with
sand
once upon a time there was a young girl
Well, I worked six years more or less in
Google and was on multiple computers and
because I had done development with a
bunch of technologies and I found myself in
an event teaching Latino kids to
program and I got off the stage and
a lady grabbed one of those aunts and
said you are so good at what you do and
I
and this is not what i do
but in that I said
Not if I missed all my part
technique to be able to teach the
Guys, let's program. Could it be that there is something that
I can
make them combine the two things and then
the turns that the world gave in some
moment they canceled the project in which
I was on Google and I remembered a
dude who had told me Ah I am
and he worked at Google And so I contacted him
And eventually I ended up working for
Google Chrome and that's what I do
right now
work either of you want
continue if it is my case
I have been organizing technical communities
since 2001 since I was 17 years old
over there with a Linux group ago
I think Adrián has been away for a long time
here helped me and
long time involved with community
since 2011 with communities of
javascript and many what one does with
communities is what one does in
this profession
it got to a point where i was already
working
the theme of
teach to empower other people
so that they have better skills of
share knowledge always
I was very passionate and in this company I
I was doing it but in a way
very very small, that is, my impact was very
little boy was doing consulting
being training then I was leaving
trained or taught a group of ten
people in a company and one says yes
but I want more the impact that I carry
doing in communities far greater than
What am I doing here at work?
When I realized that they were paying for
that started
to literally look for who is
hiring a duty the operative
I found several companies I did processes
in one I did not pass in others and I passed and I
They hired me and I've been here for four years now
I think it was something very similar and there is
like a pachón here I don't know if they notice
this
this is the joy of teaching gambling
to motivate to lift others I think
what is something that
which at least for me is something that
It motivates a lot I was working on
Vienna as a freelancer because of course
since I am Chilean and I had no good no
had a visa
I had to, well, I had a student visa
So they won't let me enter the market
of employment then of course I became clear and
I liked it I learned a lot but I felt a
little isolated so I started to get involved
in all that they were and all that
are the conferences but I am
sick and shy not really
But what happened then I decided to start
to teach children to program in
the school where i used to go i thought look
if i can start how to talk teach and
how is that good to work with
children I found it a blessing
because
they ask questions
they really leave me
a question one Hey and why is it called
a
and I was like
we have a little teddy
look and that that class asks that class
curiosity where I what I could contribute
was
show them how i learn
show them how I solve I left
realizing and I was in several things
various organizations
that was like
an organization where we made for
to be able to pay people His represented in
the world around the world to power
learn to program opens
and doing that kind of thing gave me
account
I would love to do this for life
A day came where I don't know where I was
it was 2000 it was the pandemic and I started to
think I actually said all this that
I have to give a talk about organizing
events and all that these are skins from
put on my resume what's up and something
A friend of mine passed by Jessica wrote to me
The other day Ramón told me Look, I saw that
you're looking for a hit, I said well
Of course I'm looking
and he tells me look I have I have I am
I don't want to work full time
you want to divide it you bring your
technical skills I bring I bring
mine of strategy that that too
strategy is something else
you want to do it and I said okay yes for
please and well that's how things started
because someone gave me a chance to
me that is something that I have realized that
it happens to me a lot
it happens to everyone a lot that someone
someone believes in us and you say oh
And that is something that I want to do and it is
something that allows me to do
I find it great and in fact it has
given now that they were talking these
little things like they talked a little about
the number of things that were
doing and certain skills that
they had a super good link with me
next question why precisely
because the next one is when you
they talked about this whole story from o
how they started this process a little bit
of how how they started What skills
you think you are the ones who have been most
served apart from the technical part
maybe but of course things like you
say Ah with stability I This was what
that triggered me before your power
find work be able to talk to
people etc.
What skills does one need to have?
warrior
I don't know exactly when it was but James
Spencer a couple of years ago
proposed that we rename the
what is what the core yes the core
from a developer And that's what I like
that changed my perspective because
clear to be able to because Because many of
these are for example
communication
delegate Listen
understand read teach learn all this
I think that for me it is one of the most
important
one word empathy
[Music]
and we're leaving See you later
I'm going to I'm going to elaborate first we
we are in a in a position that has
a lot of exposure when being hoarded
giving talk
also having the responsibility of
we educate people and give a good
message
to receive people who are arriving
with us to ask more questions
We have to have a lot of empathy to
first have the humility to be able
we manage to carry that message that
be a message
healthy that is not a stained message a
selfish message because many people
who see this profession as oops these
are the ones who travel these are the ones
They have the exhibition I want to do it
just for that And suddenly That's not the
true motivation motivation must
to be more is me How can I do to
impact others for that I need
have empathy I must like them
communicate with people
interact with people to
be able to relate to be able to listen
to be able to talk I need to have that
empathy for me that is the one we say
which sums up all the rest
The real clumsiness
whatever when
we are in development industry A
sometimes we have a bit of ego and a
little like this vision of us
We are the ones who know that I am the one
engineer and he doesn't know anything there is very
hard to be an engineer they are so
smart and real Sometimes there are
people who literally come to tell me
Hey if you can do it maybe I
that's the message too That's all
that I want that
it reaches the people that little by little
and that we all start from scratch That's right
how is it going
Hey and it exists today because I see them at
you three up here and i know a couple
of people more a while ago the
concept of operating because it existed and
had grown and a gold already appear a lot
more on social networks but today
What I really like is that it is
there is the concept but it is now in
Spanish and there That's what they feel
deserve I mean all the rest of the
community that exists to me what touches me
it's like good latino in this thing
So that's why I want to ask you.
field today to do this
effectively And connect with the
space of Latin America speaking in
Spanish
a very wise man just said there
back It is that they realized that there
six hundred million eggs
speaking Spanish
[Music]
Yes, there is a field and it is extremely necessary.
I go to YouTube and what I get is not
are the
We know that there is always something like that little thing
with which one connects with what is
house and besides
you are doing like two jumps you have to
learn all the technical issue that already
It's hard and you have to learn it
language that is not yours then why
Latinos and those who speak Spanish
we have not empowered ourselves to teach
the people of us no no jerk is like that
this is a variable
and things like that
The good thing is that there are companies that already
Let's say large companies that are already
established in Latin America that are
beginning to see the need for
connect with the public
Latin America one of the let's say of the
activities that mainly
through ambassadors or Google
experts or this type of program that
have these companies to
encourage and motivate people
that they are somehow
Let's say something tangential like that
company when seeing that more people
they are taking interest in that product already
they begin to see the strategy oops
we need or a group of people That
is dying in charge of ya
manage a veloper strategy
relations in Latin America example that
we have here other companies that we have
been able to interview on a program that
we have in Twitter spaces with another
github buddy named the real
in Spanish we have been able to interview
more people who are already driving
programs
Latin America and are hiring and
Latin America is not only talking
Spanish but also looking at the market
in Brazil and hiring people in Brazil
to generate content in Brazil in
Portuguese too and sorry
on the other side of the planet is this
topic already in general specifically in
Spanish maybe a little more complex or or
equal
I think that in the same way that
we are seeing and Well clear as
that we are doing more in the networks
social we are seeing them in other
parts of the world too that are also
speaks Spanish. For example, I can
say that in Spain there is a great
world of del Real that is growing from to
little and and what what what
what makes me smile is that he sees several
modes and surely several people here
can have this meaning also this
feeling too
There are things we do at work
newspaper that are technically online
problem is that it was missing that
definition was missing how to say
was missing as the name
I think that as we go
exposing this more and Well I will I can
make a little
Yes because next week there will be
online la depre with latam that is free
and online and one of the one of the King
outers is here with me
[laughs]
and I believe that I believe that having the
have these conversations open
where we say This is what it is And this
is what you can as we go
having this more we are asking for more
in these local communities I believe that
is giving us that ability to have
those roles and I have several questions
more but I don't have much time but
I could be sitting much more than anything
but I had a question for you, perhaps a
a little shorter and then I have the
last and with that we close but
usually like Because when one
Analyze current job
software developer not that today in
day they look at us for lines of code
maybe still in some company like that
but maybe I'm sorry a little more
concrete and me from the outside
I don't know how they define success in a job
of network by the conferences of which
you travel is
because of the number of people who
share How can you define this thing
means of interacting with people to
say ah yes it's working
That's the eternal joke in how to get out of
roadmap for developers
How to measure what metrics what what what
complicated exactly that at least
has been my experience so far and
Well, what you are looking for is like that
impact did your work have
How many developers are using the
technologies the technologies that
you are driving to use and for that there is
different techniques at the end of the day
maybe it touches you the same as a
developer make tools was the
successfully accepted tool It is more
this type of
interaction with people
It is a work of connection with the
people and then it's your turn to find one
way to save that data and and
keep it there to be able to teach that
said something don't just sit down talk to
Philip
very difficult question because also
even varies greatly in organizations and
there are organizations that at this time
they're still watching as they do
How to measure the success of an area
relations And also depending on the
organization is where you are
inside the orchard inside the
organizational hierarchy the network area
is below engineering is below
product is under marketing and there is
organizations that have it differently
where i work in celforce we
has a developer marketing area
we report to marketing ourselves as
drink we generate content we make
contact with developers
we provide feedback we create applications
example we take care of more than everything
throughout the content and
interaction with our
developers our community
and marketing is the one that is already in charge of
measure the impact They are the ones who
have their tools to measure that
type of impact then It is depending
also from the organization Like what
strategies you have to measure what is
doing
Yes, I think the complicated thing is that
many of what is done
really measured in the long term
it is not something that one does something and from then on
six months we have a million users
and from there we see it was because we did ABC
then and there exist framework
to be able to do this for example a
that I always recommend
one like to fit
Let's say for example against the goals
of the company the things that one is
doing if they collaborate with it
but of course that depends on the
organization depends all that then
It is a question that I know is asked very often.
often you are constantly watching me
I imagine after two three months
six months now how we do this
metric we are measuring what
we should be measuring what is
Complex the subject comes out in the Falcon box
and the other is you have a company
who has a duel doing everything and
you have other companies that have six
seven different teams of the operative
working for different products
So how to measure
a little difficult today I have it fits me super
little time to be able to make one
last question but
I have to have to like to travel
to work no no oh no oh yeah
cut the question
you can put a little because I think that
one of the things that one of the things
that from the outside I know maybe a little
confusing that one sees those who do
all conferences in all
events in all videos but how
we said at the beginning it's not a it's a field
quite large than where there are several
role classes for example
there is one will not be in front of the
camera all the time
What's it called
where one is doing like
interacting directly with
company customers I think I was
time ran out today with they told us but
I agree
you can finish the point no problem
Well
to say something is that
everything we see on social media
like all things in life is
only one portion not to have
Ten thousand followers on Twitter for
be in there must have a one
giant a giant YouTube channel for
be there is no need to have a tweet already already
I said nothing of what Ramón mentioned I have
And this is the second time I travel
that's why and I already have two years in this thing
so what Ramón said
Actually I'm not going to I don't know if there is
a dignified way to stand on these
little things
that nothing can be taken inside the
theater
Why do situations like these happen?
I want to give you infinite thanks
let's let's take advantage eventually
but I want to thank you very much for
his time for sitting down to talk
with us for a while in this world
medium that we may not know from the
concept of So I ask you all
you a big round of applause for the
guys
remember february ninth
Latin America that totally online
free
that the boys are
appearing
the talk will be with the talk I'm going to
to find my partner is going to be how
is born and we are going to tell all that
Hey, I'm going to stay for two seconds
top to fill in please
give me two seconds to order
to fill to fill more
Hey look Ah entertainment this is
part of the team that we have
developing or doing all
conference with us can give us
an applause please
the thing is
because you have seen me
I mean outside talking
reloading the what is this called
the air conditioners bouncing and
putting water moving millions of
things making everything work
making this thing work yeah
us
Maybe we have thrown it away as a joke but
we climbed up here to
stage and we don't go down anymore we stay
above we do not know what happens here
outside and the ones that are not really done
pass this this event and make everything
happen out there it's the boys so
I am infinitely grateful for him
awesome support you locked me in
back there to go out alone and you dirty
I need Ricardo
Hey
I needed vacation thanks
this must be attended Yes or yes it will
be very
I don't find it very entertaining and
precisely for this reason I also wanted
be up here so we can talk
with the boys and ask them questions to
learn because there really are certain
things that escaped me as of course the
idea of ​​this that
the range of things inside
and how can you live and if
do you need to travel or not I don't get angry
traveling
there is always the question of what is
What does it do at the end and can you fix it?
It kind of gives you that maybe-me approach.
I also want to be something
it happens a lot so well it was the best
this panel I really loved it yes I
they had back watching it But hey
my heart will remain forever
Hey We have to continue That's right
the afternoon is technically short
we still have a couple of
little chats yes a break other little chats and
let's go to closing no then we have to
enjoy all that's left they are i think
that like four more hours
that is, then we can tell you the
surprise that the morning continues
Sunday no but since all this already
someone from home asked somewhere
moment at least I do wonder if
the question was Felipe How can we
help make changes in language is
say I don't know I want to add a
new type of something how I propose it
Like, what do I do? I mean, I send a PR to something
and they approved it
air
I imagine not I want to believe
that it was not like that especially because I have
things in production that
but I do not understand that fed up more
complex but i don't have real real
knowledge so what
coincidentally that's good to do
that question true why Sure why
our next
a little that yes we are lucky today
that joins us from this scenario
our next speaker he
spider man
So today we want to leave you with him
in order to learn a lot about what
are doing today and solve
all these doubts so a strong
round of applause for daniel maynor
[Music]
and the first time I'm giving a
chat in spanish
So
we don't believe each other
with my slides
better thanks
then he introduced me i am damaged
here spider man
I want to start with a question why
today we will focus on languages
can be natural languages
constructed languages ​​the languages ​​of
computing
but i have to think about it
It's what I'm most afraid of that's like
I'm going to block myself but in this case
the languages
we are interested
and of course it is something that we have to know
for our work
our jobs but other than that it's
something personal what do you think in my case
I am fascinated by the interactions between
human aspects and concepts
technical
the perfect language seems to me to believe
in language creating a language is a
act of hope of idealism
but also the interpreters are
fascinating programs are full of
deep computer concepts and
mathematics as logic languages
formal
compilation trees
the first time i created a program for
interpret and it worked I think it turned out
that there are two plus two is four but for
me it was like my show had its own
life as doctor monster
Frankenstein and today I am lucky to
work with a stop engine and still
I am excited to work with
programs And yes I hope I can
share this emotion with you
So the people of Uruguay want you to
let's go with a proposal step by step
of a proposal and more importantly How
can contribute to the process
technical
that allows you to create
standalone implementations like
spider man
and also and programs with rights of
property
well it is formed by a group of
companies and also organizations
So how does the committee work?
works very tactfully by suggestions
and markings of the proposals with
compromise agreements and with many
conversations outside unions
Now we are going to talk about the stages of
a proposal
and period the proposal needs some
mushrooms are called English are the
people proposing the proposal and
also a text with a description
Clear of the problem and it means that the
committee expects
the time to the program during the first
stage the Champions are going to be a
argument to change the language and
develop a sketch of a solution
identifiable and face-to-face programs and
seven means the proposal must
be part of the specification
the second stage the Champions are going to
describe precisely
the semantics of the change using the
informal language of the Y specification
if dance means the one who brings me think
that the proposal is ready for
implementation Y storm and the third
stage javascript engines do their
implementations and therefore the
specification is more less stable no
open more very big changes to
found programs exception
during implementation or finally by
example programs with compatibility
in this case Advance needs trouble
list in 162 new test libraries
and also two confrontations
independent independent in motors
the proposal will be included in the next
specification edition
Why one purpose They can say many
reasons may be the idea there is no
Sufficient justification for a change
It may be the intention of the prophet to
change a lot from inner ages or
it is like a solution that is
looking for a program
and that is why I am going to speak from the point of
spider-man view here and we are
conservatives with eggs
and our users are all
people
who live in North America or Europe and the
web compatibility is very important
for us
I would like to present an example
as we have seen until tomorrow and in this
case the proposal was to create to visit
the creation of groups in networks This
very similar example that there is until tomorrow
we have a network of numbers and we are going to
make the groups one in pairs
the other for
a brief history
of add
to avoid bruising close together
filter keeps or discards elements and
that helps only the first stage
to explore how to improve
the second and third stages
Let's start with our implementation in
Spiderman King we had the first
implementation of this proposal and was
college volunteers
for this proposal almost all the public
was developed
it's called code
and many times the implementation of a
proposal only needs knowledge of
javascript
but after a while we found a
serious problem in firefox
and we quickly described that it was because
there point
and many versions
incompatible group and it's kind of
modification is called
in English
Although the program already well lengthened in
new versions
we can't break users
and in fact
there were over a thousand sites that had this
problem and trying to contact everyone
but did not have a 700 response for
avoid a name change and therefore to
a man was changed
this principle of a web project is very
very important to us
but after a while we found
even more problems with a groups not
it works with a man there is no
employment and another at point ch or who
knows and the symptoms in all cases
Although the website ends it from but
it was not and far ahead
and now we don't want to change a name to
again and find that they open
more problems
but that is normal and does not mean
that will not return to the third age
have a good understanding of the problem
Now I would like to talk a little
on the implementation of a proposal
to my example the implementation
That's something a little personal. It's my
first big project on spiderman but
part of this seems like a good example to me
to work with a forehead in an engine
Why do I have to modify the token?
and those are three most important parts
of this engine source
I want to start with a brief description
of each part to make it more
modifications that are necessary to
the implementation
And first we have the
token is an indivisible part
to build a tree
third part we have the generation of
pager
this tree
and the peaks are also the entrance to the
compilers
in other parts of the engine
We also have to know that it is a
dakarter is a common concept I think
in other languages ​​and I also think that
I don't have enough time to
talk about everything but I would like
present as the iconic example
with property a class and in this
example as examples will write
insurance
when the class is created
here we have a little more example
complicated
this time we are going to start the method with
something new
then implantation
with the tokens
spider-man and are on a list in Edge
and more or less everything I had to add
I don't know what they are called in Spanish but at
same time i made changes in for
control the
in this case I had to build a
list of for each method property
and class in the implementation
here is At least three ways to
define a data and apparently has to
handle with everyone
and a more complicated part
you have to generate
with the necessary arguments and also
trigger
results
in my first example we will respect
result if it is in function it has to
store the result somewhere and
that's like my second example where
we start the method and if it is something
different is wrong
so
last part. In my opinion the topic is
important is how you can contribute
but I want to start because you would think Y
that's something personal too
can i speak my point of view
backpack employee
is a non-profit organization and
from the beginning we have had a
manifest that it is our day and within
this principle principle always me
attracts attention and this is training is
a global public resource that should
remain open and accessible and in my
opinion
is a global public resource is
important to everyone
like to train not only
that's why they are from North America or
Europe but I have seen
very few people make the decisions
about the future and we need the ideas
and participation of more people
So how can you contribute?
but it doesn't matter all the proposals
they are restless and we also observe
other technical or important
on the new proposals and another for
the people that
developed tools such as Tools and
you can contact automatae on this channel
from Matrix
if you feel like writing code
you can create a stick for new
proposal you can contribute a
implementation for bebo bebo is like the
change
future and has implementations of
new proposals before they are in
javascript engines And also
you can write new problems in
our test library test 262
And you can also contribute to
spider-mania to many of the proposals
by volunteers. And that can be a good
way to learn how a
engine and also have an influence
about the future of language in this
pack there is a list of all
proposals that were in the third
stage and you can look for the proposals that
they still need an implementation
I need I need a little
knowledge to work with
spider man font
And of course
In my opinion this book
It is excellent and has almost everything you have
What to know to start working with
an interpreter and even spider-man And if
Do you have any questions or comments I can
contact us on our channel
Well, nothing. Thank you very much.
thanks to the guy
to all the people
Thank you very much for your time and attention
that
[Music]
Hey, I find it great and you
I wanted to say thank you for making your
talk in Spanish Yes because that is not given
that is not the Norm and for me
I really like it a lot
The spoon is fully appreciated
Thank you very much thank you very much
applause for
a couple of reviewers and ready to convince you
gave me hope that I could do something
important
we can all help that hey
[Music]
yes you are absolutely right
sorry
the journey continues Yes the journey continues and
we passed again and took a plane and
We went to Poland that's the Poland
I am very surprised that
let's have people so far because the flight
It is not minor but we are perhaps
we are not Magellan but we are fine
far from arriving here is not that
be so easy then I am very
grateful that people want to travel
as Ricardo said our next
sticker is from poland
she was working with a on the console
blue
asura
azurante or for pardon
there there I have a good hand
wonderful Hey it's a project
wonderful if you have a moment if you
you can see take a look that right here